This is Jocko podcast number
one 58 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
There was blood all over the
floor and smoke in the air.
I heard shots fired outside,
but I wasn't quite sure who was
shooting or what they were shooting at.
Okay.
I moved down the hallway confirming
that all the rooms had been cleared.
I soon found the source of the blood.
I wounded Iraqi civilian on
who my seal hospital corpsman.
A highly trained combat medic was
working to apply medical care.
Yeah,
and that's just a short little
opening from chapter two of the book,
the dichotomy of leadership with a that
I wrote with my brother Leif Babin and
in that chapter I go on to explain how
during this operation in Fallujah Iraq,
we went on to detain multiple
suspected terrorists that night.
And I don't go into much detail about
that and I don't talk about the people
that we captured. We
tick, I think we've took,
I think we took about
13 people off target,
military aged males. We were probably
looking for two or three. We weren't,
couldn't figure out or
confirm who they were.
So we brought all the military aged
males off target and so we end up at this
detention facility and we're turning
these individuals over and I'm sitting
there kind of
just looking at him,
just sizing him up.
This was one of their earliest
operations I had done in my life.
It was the first big
operation I did in Iraq.
And so I'm sort of curious,
I guess for lack of a better word,
and I'm looking at the people
that we had captured. Like I said,
I think there's 13 of them
and just looking at them,
looking at their emotions that they were
going through and some of them looks
scared, right. In fact, I would say
the majority from just look scared,
just this is not good and this is a bad
situation. And you get that feeling like,
okay, this guy is probably
not bad and will be released.
Some of the guys looked mad, which
is understandable to, you know,
someone comes into your house in the
middle of night and then takes you and you
can be mad about that. If you can
overcome the scared part. Right.
And of course these people had
lived under Saddam Hussein,
so they'd been through some brutal stuff.
And for them to be not afraid
was also an understandable thing.
Some of the older gentlemen.
And then
there was one guy though that he looked,
he looked different.
The look in his eyes,
it will definitely wasn't scared,
but it wasn't even mad.
It was like beyond mad.
It was beyond angry.
It was beyond a fanatical look.
The look that he had in his
was evil look like any evil.
We could see evil there and I
never will forget that that face
and I would see that type of
face again over the years.
Yeah,
especially in Iraq,
you'd go out and capture someone that
was known for doing horrible things and
you could tell you need grab five
or six people and you'd say, Oh,
let me guess which one is the bad guy.
And usually wasn't very hard to tell.
And then occasionally some of
those bad guys would just look,
they looked completely evil. They look
like sadists, they look like murderers.
They, they had the face of evil.
You could see it in their eyes.
And I was,
yeah,
watching a video recently of a,
a young,
beautiful young girl,
blonde hair,
kind of unkempt blonde hair,
a little bit wild,
and she had a like a constant persistent
smile sort of shining on her face.
She had young little innocent
eyes that were filled with hope.
Okay.
And I watched this video and
she says in the video she says,
my name is Louisa.
I'm young lady from Denmark and I have
a burning desire to go out into the
Arctic. And she's going on kind
of describing herself. She says,
I'm very enthusiastic about the
outdoors and outdoor activities.
I'm studying outdoor life,
Norway for this same reason.
I'm trying to find my dream.
She says to go into the Arctic,
but sometimes I take some detours before
I end up where I want in the video.
She's got clips of her in various parts
of the world on beaches and in jungles
and she's clearly a traveler.
And then she says,
but I'm still working my
way towards the north.
Yeah,
a dream that has been stuck in my head
and I hope,
wish and pray
that I can retrieve my dream,
our dream of experiencing the feeling
of kicking a dog sled through the big
Arctic
about feeling the ice crystals in my face,
in the view of an
infinite white landscape.
I dream about learning and
experiencing the magnificent,
untamed Arctic.
And the video ends with her picking
up snow in her hands and she blows it
innocently into the camera
lens and she's laughing.
Okay.
And then the video fades,
but she was not able to fulfill her dream.
In fact,
she entered a nightmare
and didn't return
on December 17th,
2018 that girl who made that video,
her name was Louisa Jespersen
and her friend Marin Youland,
another beautiful young lady from Norway.
They were browth brutally,
brutally murdered by a group of
subhuman savages
as they camped beside a
hiking trail in Morocco.
And these despicable in viral people.
And I use that term loosely,
these,
these savages that murdered these two
girls actually recorded their disgusting
acts and posted them on mine.
Yeah.
They
attack these girls.
They saw through their
throats with butcher knives
while they were still alive.
Okay.
While they were screaming,
while they were gasping for air,
while they were begging for mercy and
while they were eventually gurgling in
their own blood
and then fell silent,
and one of the murderers put his foot
on one of the girls' heads to hold her
neck in place while he finished the job
of decapitating her.
Yeah,
and these sub humans pledged
their allegiance to isis
and shouted,
it's all laws will
as they killed these
innocent girls.
Okay.
Sick,
depraved
vial
creatures,
evil.
Yeah.
Evil does exist.
Here's a nother example
of evil.
I started doing time when I was 11 years
old and have been doing practically
nothing else since then. What
time? I haven't been in jail.
I've spent either getting
out or getting in again.
Yeah.
I have no desire,
whatever to reform myself.
My only desire is to reform
people who try to reform me,
and I believe the only
way to reform people
is to kill them.
In my lifetime,
I have murdered 21 human beings.
I've committed thousands of
burglaries, robberies, larcenies,
arsons,
and last but not least,
I have committed sodomy on more
than 1000 male human beings.
For all of these things, I
am not the least bit, sorry,
I have no conscience,
so that doesn't worry me.
Okay.
I don't believe in man,
God nor devil.
I hate the whole damn human race.
Yeah.
Including myself.
I prayed upon the week,
the harmless and the unsuspecting.
This lesson I was taught by others
might makes right
Carl Pans Ram number
three one six one four
and that is the opening
of a book called Pans.
Ram.
Journal of a murderer.
Yeah,
Carl Pans.
Ram was evil.
He was institutionalized for most of his
life in detention centers and prisons
and whatever may have been good about
him at one time or another was eventually
suffocated.
And what was left was
pure on mitigated hatred
and malevolence.
And while he was going through
one of his final stance in prison,
he made friends with a young
prison by the name of Henry Lesser.
Then Henry lesser seemed like
a very good positive person.
Kind of had the ideal of reform.
Now people could be helped in his mind,
and Henry asked that Pans Ram,
right? The story of his life, which,
which pans ram did.
Yeah.
Then the notes were save,
saved and documented,
and there was additional information from
various supporting sources surrounding
other details of pans, rams, life,
and all of that was put together
and turned into this book,
which though it is a very difficult read.
Yeah.
It's in my opinion, worth reading
to gather a better understanding of
of human nature and specifically
of the capacity for men
to commit evil.
So again, most of this that I'm
going to read from the book is
his work, his writing,
Carl pans, rems, writing.
And here we go. Back to the
book. I was born June 28th,
1891 on a small farm in
Minnesota. My parents were of
German descent, hardworking,
ignorant,
and poor.
The rest of the family consisted
of five brothers and one sister,
all of whom are dead except three
of us brothers and our sister.
All of my family are as the
average human beings are.
They're honest and hardworking people.
All except myself.
I've been a human animal ever since
I was born. When I was very young,
at five or six years of age, I was a
fief and a liar and the older I got,
the meaner I got
as fast as the older boys grew up,
they also pulled out one died.
They, this left me and my sister,
one older brother and my mother.
Okay.
My sister and I were sent to school during
the days and as soon as we came home
in the evenings,
we were put to work in the fields where
my older brother and my mother were
always at work from daylight
until long after dark.
Sometimes my portion of pay consisted
of plenty of work and a sound,
a beating.
Every time I looked cockeyed or done
anything that displeased anyone who is
older and stronger and Cape and able
to catch me and kick me around whenever
they felt like it and it seemed to me
and still does now that everything was
always right for the one who was the
strongest and every single thing that I'd
done was wrong.
Okay.
Everybody said so anyway, but right or
wrong, I used to get plenty of abuse.
Everybody thought it was all
right to deceive me, lie to
me, and kicked me around.
Whenever they felt like it,
then they felt like it pretty regular.
Yeah.
That is the way my life was lived
until I was about 11 years old.
At about that time,
I began to suspect that there was
something wrong about the treatment I was
getting from the rest of the human race.
When I was about 11 years old,
I began to hear and see that there were
other places in this world besides my
own little corner of it.
I began to realize that there
were other people who live nice,
easy lives and were not kicked
around and work to death.
Yeah.
I decided that I wanted to leave
my miserable home before I left.
I looked around and figured that one
of our neighbors who was rich and had a
nice home full of Nice things,
hat he had too much and I had two little
so one night I broke into his home and
stole everything to that to my eyes.
Had the most value,
those things where some apples,
some cake and a great big pistol.
Okay.
Eating the apples and cake and
carrying the pistol under my coat.
I walked to the railroad yards where I
caught a freight train going to the West
where I intended to be a
cowboy and shoot Indians,
but I must've had my wires crossed
because I missed my connection somewhere.
Instead of going out and seeing the world,
I was caught,
brought back home and beaten half to
death and sent to jail from there.
And from there to the Minnesota state
training school at Redwing, Minnesota.
Yeah,
right there. And then I began to
learn about man's inhumanity to man.
So he's off to a rough start and it was
his father had left him and I didn't
mention that part. Obviously I'm
not reading every part of the book,
but his father left the family
and then it was up to his mom.
Sounds like he had the, uh,
more than his share of the,
the rebellious streak that
I think most kids have.
And then he shows up at this Minnesota,
Minnesota state training
school back to the book.
When I first went to the Minnesota
state trait, the state training school,
I was about 12 years old, lively,
healthy, and very mischievous,
innocent and ignorant. The law immediately
proceeded to educate me to be a good,
clean, upright citizen and
a credit to the human race.
They trained me all right in that
training school, during my two years,
I was trained by two different sets of
people to have two different sets of
morals.
The good people tried to train me to be
good and the bad people did train me to
be bad.
Yeah.
The method that the good people used in
training was to beat goodness into me
and all the badness out of me.
They'd done their best,
but their best wasn't good enough to
accomplish what they set out to do.
The more they beat me and whipped me,
the more I hated them and
they're damn religion.
Oh yes. We had plenty of
church and religion. All right.
I used to be pretty ignorant
and not able to read very well,
so I was always had a hard job learning
my Sunday school lessons for failure to
learn these lessons. I was
given a whipping during
the first year I was there.
I used to get a beating every Saturday
night and sometimes three or four more
during the week for doing something I
wasn't supposed to do or for not doing
something I was supposed to do.
Oh yes. I had plenty of abuse.
They had various methods of punishing us
for doing wrong and for teaching us to
do right.
The most popular with them was
to take us to the paint shop,
so called because there they used
to paint our bodies black and blue.
Naturally. I now love
Jesus very much, much.
Yes.
I love him so damn much that I would
like to crucify him all over again.
Yeah.
I was too dumb to learn
anything in school,
so they took me out and put me to work
all day washing dishes and waiting on
tables and the officer's
dining room right there.
I began to get a little revenge on those
who abused me when I served some food
to the some of the officers I
used to urinate in their soup,
coffee or tea and masturbate into their
ice cream or dessert and then stand
right beside them and watch them eat it.
They enjoyed it too because they told
me so. I wish they could read this. Now
the next thing I tried to do as poison
that Mr John more by putting rat poison
in his rights, rice
pudding, but they caught me,
beat me,
and put me out of the dining room.
About that time I began to try and
figure out some way to punish those who
punished me.
The only thing I could figure out was
to burn down the building in which the
paint shop was located.
This I did
okay.
I've got a long,
thick piece of heavy cotton string
wrapped it around and around a long round
stick and lit what end of it and hit it
in the laundry near some oil soaked rags
that night.
The whole place burned down in a cost
of a hundred over a hundred thousand
dollars Nicei
some of the boys who were clever than
I finally put me wise to how I should
perform.
If I ever wanted to get out of that joint.
They told me to act like
I was a very good boy.
Tell everybody I met how much I love
Jesus and how I wanted to go home and be a
good boy.
Go to school and learn to be a preacher.
Okay.
I done just as they suggested and I'm
damned if it didn't work out just as slick
as hot grease through a tin horn.
Yeah.
I was called in before the parole board
one day and there I told them all the
lies and hot air I could and they
gave me a parole and let me go home.
In that way,
I first found out how to use religion
as a cloak of hypocrisy to cover up my
rascality.
He's
okay.
Rough way to kick things off.
Yeah. But you almost like,
you know, you talk about like evil,
you almost feel it for him though,
are on his side, kind of like, yeah.
It won't just beating you up your whole
life making just grinding into I'm
beating you up. And then
like, yes, you're getting it.
That's how you feel right now.
Yeah. Well it's, it's one of
those things that's going to be,
you know,
yeah.
You feel sympathetic for
someone and then you as,
as that person moves through
life, first of all, it's,
there's other people that had been through
worse things that turn out great and
wonderful human beings.
And there's other people that go through
last that turned out worse. Right.
So there's, it's, it's,
uh, I'm no psychologists,
but there's,
there's,
it's one of the things
that's troubling about this
and as you,
as you hear what he goes through
and when he turns into it's,
yeah, it's, it's definitely
a challenge. And you know,
at the end of the day in,
in my opinion, like, hey,
you're still responsible
for your actions and hey,
we get it that you went
through some hard things
that doesn't give you an excuse
to behave in an immoral way.
It just doesn't.
Yeah, it doesn't, I'm sure
that, um, you know, like he,
he was saying how he was,
you know, pissing in the soup
and whatnot. I mean, I'm,
I'm assuming those of the people who
were like trying to correct them and you
know, I'm beating him on
staff, the staff of the,
of the school where he
was being trained at.
So I think that's sort of why you're like
kind of feeling for them because it's
like,
oh yeah,
you're getting direct revenge on that
kind of thing and you're of course you're
angry kid. Yeah, of course. What
you went through. But then yeah,
once you start just taking it out like,
oh, let me see an innocent person,
I'm mad at them because their life is,
and then you kill him or something,
then that's when you're going to
start to not feel for them. I'm sure.
I think. Yeah, I think so too. Yeah.
I guess you do get that kind of feeling
like all these guys are beating you up
now you're getting a little revenge.
You could,
you could make a positive
movie about that. Right?
You could make a positive story that
you can spin it. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
depending on where it goes from there.
So right now you're,
you're on his side basically
basic and back to the book,
after serving about two years there,
I was pronounced by the Parole
Board to be a nice, clean boy.
Have good morals as pure as a lily and
a credit to those in authority in the,
in the instruction where I had been sent
to be reformed. Yes, sure. I was reformed.
All right. Damn good. And reform
too. When I got out of there,
I knew all about Jesus and the Bible so
much so that I knew it was a lot of hot
air.
Okay.
But that wasn't all I knew.
I had been taught by Christians
how to be a hypocrite.
Okay.
And I had learned about stealing,
lying, hating, burning, and killing
from the treatment I received while
there and the lessons I learned from it.
I had fully decided when I left there,
just how I would live my life.
I made up my mind that I would rob burn,
destroy,
and kill everywhere I went and
everybody as long as I lived.
That's the way I was reformed in
the Minnesota state training school.
That's the reason why,
so that's a little bit more that that's,
that's where you have something
in his, in his personality, right.
There's something,
there's plenty of people that went to
this school that didn't go do what he did.
He made that stair something snapped.
Yeah.
Where he decided that he was just going
to make his life a life of making people
suffer.
Going on back to the book,
I did not want to learn these lessons,
but I found out that it isn't what
one wants in this world. That one gets
force and might make. Right. Perhaps
things shouldn't be that way,
but that's the way they are.
I learned to look with suspicion
and hatred on everybody.
Okay.
As the years went on, that persisted
in my mind. That persisted.
That idea persisted in my mind.
Above all others.
I figured that if I was strong enough
and clever enough to impose my will on
others,
I was right.
Yeah.
I still believe that to this day.
So this is just this twisted. Yeah, it's
really, it doesn't take long for him.
They get pretty twisted.
Okay.
In like there's a lesson here of
who the lesson that he talks about.
If I found out that it isn't in the,
what one wants in a world that one gets,
it's like that's actually
an important lesson.
Like you don't always get what you
want, but then taking that to say, Hey,
if I'm strong enough and I
can force my will on things,
then I'll get what I want more often.
Yeah. And the in that he did
say clever enough to, yeah.
Which kind of,
it's weird cause like a real low,
super low level of that
still goes on I think with,
with a lot of people there,
no doubt about it. You know,
with justification and you know how
like, you know, you'll, you know, you'll,
you'll justify things in your head,
you know, it'd be like, Oh, you know,
when you do something bad, will you
do something, you know, is unfair.
Even that kind of low level stuff,
like it's not hurting no bunch for sure,
but it's like maybe not
fair or something like that.
Then you'd just justify in your head.
And you know,
like some people they're clever.
Like they're smart so they can justify
their justifications are way more legit
seeming. Cause they're real smart.
They can just, you know, yeah.
It's kind of like with lawyers, you see
the lawyers doing the movie, you know,
you paint for someone to
be like someone like the,
you kind of take things out of context
and put other things in context and not
supposed to be there kind of thing.
And Yeah,
you just kind of paint this picture in
your own mind why what you're doing is
right. And of course in other
people's mind too, you know,
then you're clever enough, Daniel,
you're justifying it yourself and he's,
but he's not even talking about that.
He doesn't need to justify it to himself.
He's doing what he's doing to,
to get what he wants.
And his use of being clever
isn't to justify to himself
his use of being clever.
It's just to outwit people and
take advantage of them. Yeah.
Be a con man beyond a con man.
And he gets,
so he's in and out of prison and he goes
back into prison. He gets out of prison.
He goes back into present here. At this
point, he broke out of prison and he's,
he hooks up with a guy named Jimmy Benson.
Back to the book.
He showed me how to work the stickup
racket and how to rob the poor boxes in
churches. I in turn taught him how to
set fire to a church after we robbed it.
We got very busy on that robbing and
burning or church regular every chance we
got.
Yeah.
When we got tired of riding a train
because this is their, their uh, you know,
hitching on these trains.
When we got tired of riding on a train,
we used to open up the journal boxes,
take out the greasy waste packing and
throw in some sand or gravel into it.
They wouldn't get far with that car.
So they get done riding a train and
they just destroy it. They, you know,
they ruin the gearboxes.
Just general destruction of everything
continues in and out of prison.
One time he uses drunk and here's a
guy talking about the army and ends up
enlisting in the army.
Back to the book.
I was only in the army a month or two
when I got three years in u s military
prison at Fort Leavenworth,
Kansas.
I had the job of swinging 18
pound hammer in the rock quarry.
Most of my bit,
my number was 1874 and my
name was Karl Pans Ram there.
I done 37 months.
I done plenty of work and I had plenty
of punishment and the only good part of
it was that they didn't try
to hammer anymore religion.
And to me at this time of my life,
I was about 20 years old,
six foot tall and weighed about 190
pound of concentrated hell fired man
inspired meanness.
I was strong as two or three average men.
Yeah.
I had to be to be able to withstand
some of the punishments and labor that I
went through during my
three years in the u s um,
military prison.
One of my tasks and punishments while
there was to be shackled to a 50 pound
iron ball for six months.
During that time,
I wore the ball and chain day and night,
slept with it and work with it on my
work was in the rock quarry and that was
three miles from the prison.
The gang of about 300 convicts and 40
screws used to march out in the morning
and back at night. The other men had
to carry nothing except themselves.
But my part was to load my iron ball,
an 18 pound hammer, a pick and shovel,
and a six foot iron crowbar all into a
wheel barrow and march behind the line of
cons out to the Corey and worked there
for eight and a half hours in the hot
Kansas son busting big rocks,
but all of that treatment did one
good thing for me. The worst food was,
and the harbor,
they worked me the stronger I got,
I was going to save the, Oh, so he got
a good workout and you think, yeah,
he's six feet tall, 190
pounds back in, what is it,
1900 or whatever.
He's a yolks dude and he's doing all
this hardcore physical labor and yeah,
he's turning into a very scary dude.
Hmm.
Back to the book. I was discharged
from prison in 1910 by the way,
can you imagine?
You're in the army for a couple months
and you get put in the Leavenworth for
three years.
I was the spirit of meanness personified.
I had not at this time got
so that I hated myself.
I only hated everybody
else before I left there.
I Sung on the same old song and gave
him the same line about how I sure love
Jesus and what a nice young man I was
and how much good I it had done me to be
sent to that prison.
I don't know if they believe me or not,
but they all said they did anyway.
They all declared that I was pure
as a Lilly and free from sin.
Again, there are so a bunch of
traveling, there's a bunch of coffee.
He's a constant criminal and he,
there's another thing we realize back
in this day and the reason he named,
he said,
oh,
at this time I was Carl Pans
Ram is because he changes
his name a bunch because
that's what just what you would do back
then if you a criminal and there's no
electronic tracking system, there's
no phone numbers, no cell phone.
There's not even a fault with like phones
and everyone's houses so you can get
away with murder quite literally.
And he does, but he, he,
he's maybe not the best criminal as well
because he gets caught a lot, you know,
for robbing and stealing and part
of it's cause cause he has like a,
doesn't care it,
so he gets put,
he gets arrested at different time.
He gets put into a chain gang and he
eventually breaks away from escapes the
chain gang and then he goes
from continuing skipping
trains and ends up with an
Indian guy and they work together as a
little team and they rob a guy and here
we go back to the book of the Indian,
tied him up first he took off his belt,
pulled his pants down to below his
knees and tied his legs together.
Then he tied his hands behind his back.
Then he tied his hands to his feet,
pulled together.
Then he stuffed a sock in his mouth and
tied a handkerchief tied over that and
then tied them to a tree. He was in
ready to leave him and walk away.
But I wasn't through yet.
I figured while I had such a good chances
that I would commit a little sodomy on
him.
This I proceeded to do
and he mentioned at one point that he,
he hooked up with a girl and got
some kind of vd and then he was like,
oh girls, they're dirty. And so
that's why he goes after guys. Now
back to the book at at night,
while I was riding the freight trains,
I was always on the lookout for something
to shoot or trying to stick up the
Hobos that I met on the trains.
I looked them all over and whenever I
met one who wasn't too rusty looking,
I would make him raises
hands and drop his pants.
I wasn't very particular either.
I rode them old and young,
tall and short, white and black.
It made no difference to me.
Yeah.
Some months later I was pinched
at Chinook Montana for burglary.
I quick took a plea of guilty and got one
year at the state prison at deer lodge,
Montana. When I got there, I met
my old partner, Jimmy Benson,
who was doing 10 years for robbery.
I stayed there about eight
months in escaped he,
he's also good at escaping escapes
all these things all the time.
A week later I was
arrested in three forks,
Montana for burglary under
the name of Jeff Rhodes.
I pleaded guilty and got a year and was
sent back to deer lodge where I was at
once,
brought to court and given one year for
my escape under the name Jeff Davis.
Out of these three sentences,
I served 23 months in that prison.
There was only work for a few
men and I wasn't one of those.
All the cells were for
two men in each cell.
Each man could choose his own cell mates
and get a new one anytime he wanted.
I used to want a new one pretty regular
at that place and time I got to be an
experienced wolf.
I knew more about sodomy than old boy
Oscar Wilde ever thought of knowing.
I would start in the morning with sodomy,
work as hard as,
as hard at it as I could all day
and sometimes half the night.
I was so busy committing sodomy that I
didn't have time left to serve Jesus as I
had been taught to in
those reforms schools.
He gets out of that prison.
As soon as I got to Oregon and gets
put in another prison, I got to,
as soon as I got to Oregon State prison,
I was in more trouble.
I swore I would never do the seven
years and defied the warden and all his
officers to make me gets put in
solitary confinement. Here we go.
In solitary confinement,
there are coolers and coolers.
Some are bad and some are worse.
None are good. Some are cold and wet,
some are hot and dry.
Some you freeze and others you roast and
sweat in all you are hungry and thirsty
and filthy and in some you stay a day
or there's a week and there have been
times when I've been in
the cooler a month or more.
Bread and water isn't very nourishing
and neither does it generate clean
thinking in a person's mind.
The milk of human kindness generally
curdles and turns into sour under such
conditions.
The more cooler you get,
the more heat and hate
there is in your heart.
In every joint I was ever in,
there was always some form
of torture that was on tap.
I usually got my share
of every kind there was.
I've had them all at one time or another
and then he goes on through a bunch of
different
torture that they would use on these
prisoners from like straight jacket type
things. There's something
called the snorting Pole,
which is a post about 12 feet long. You
get basically tied to it. You get whipped
back to the book. When the lash begins
to take away, little bits of hide in,
the blood begins to run. Then the soccer
begins to jerk and Yelp and snort.
That's why it's called the snorting pole.
When a man is let down
after being whipped,
he has blood on his back
and murder in his heart.
That's, that's all about
the snorting Paul. There's a
bat and the paddle, there's,
here's this thing, the restraint
machine, the restraint machine,
bare footed,
standing on a cold damp concrete floor,
backed up to an iron bar door,
hands behind, cuffed to the door,
a large belt under my arms, around
my chest, pulled tight to the door,
standing in that position for four hours,
then let down for one hour
to eat my bread and water.
Then four hours more than to bed,
which was a board,
no blankets in the morning,
bread and water,
and then four hours more and so on for
a stretch of anywhere from five to 14
days.
That was the limit.
That's your restraint machine you've ever,
okay.
I know you're claustrophobic,
right? Sure. Yeah. I mean you are,
but sometimes I don't.
I don't think I'm claustrophobic,
but sometimes I want to
move a limb. Right. You know
what I'm saying? Well, yeah,
and for instance,
you're on a plane and you're all tight
and in economy seat up against the
bulkhead and there's
like, it's tight. Yeah.
You know that part of the plane
towards the back where the, the, the,
the bulkhead kind of curves in. So you're
even losing a little bit more space.
Yeah. And you just want
to move. Yeah. You know,
but you can't cause the seatbelt
light just went on. Yes.
Now imagine doing four hours like
that for 14 days. Four hours.
Twice a day for 14 days.
Yeah. That's horse shit. Yeah.
That's actually real harsh.
So there's like two and t to Sam Club.
Cause claustrophobia usually is like,
you know Lee,
you go in an elevator and you feel
it. That kind of, you know, I don't,
I don't have it like that,
but yeah,
maybe I'm a little bit more sensitive to
those kinds of scenarios. Side control,
claustrophobia. Well
you know I used to, yes.
But this is more what it
is to put accurately. Did I
email you? Healed me? Yeah.
Actually what it was. So it's like he,
I just got in better shape. That's all.
Cause like it wasn't,
it was the idea that if I'm like tired
and I won't be able to get out of here,
like I'm stuck here forever, I'm going
to die here. That's the feeling you get.
But when I wasn't tired, I'm like, oh
no, I can cruise down here. I just,
I don't know.
It just felt like it was better
the last time we rolled.
Didn't you have a little issue down there?
No. Are you sure? Yes.
I don't remember having any
issue recently. Probably
like year. It's been years,
but that's the feeling is what
it is. So, but here's the,
when I got an MRI on my arm,
you tap to something the other day.
That's not a tapping offense.
I forget what it was.
It was your that that forum
on my throat. Oh, I remember.
It was like I couldn't,
it was too like you did it too hard for
me to have time to figure out, okay,
I can turn this way or what a to
relieve the pain. You did it too fast.
I did it with like a little
extra, like a little, yeah.
It wasn't like a striker or
nothing like that. But yeah,
it was like I would've gotten, my
throat would have got injured if I will.
Took more time. Thanks
for that. By the way,
I had a MRI on my, Oh, you're
selling that tube. Yeah.
So which is fine if you're
just in a comfortable position.
It can be when you open your eyes
and you look how freaking tube is,
like inches in front of your
face and you're in there. Yeah,
I can kind of Jammy all,
but you just close your eyes
and be like, oh, that'll be,
claustrophobia is a big deal in the,
in the seal teams especially cause you
had to lock out of the sub submarine
chambers,
which isn't in the old days,
it was a submarine chamber that
wasn't built for seals to lock out of.
It was built for an escape hatch.
If there's an emergency
on the submarine lockout,
you're underwater in a submarine.
Yeah.
And you go into a little chamber and
then once you're in a little chamber,
it fills with water,
equalize to the outside and then the
door opens up and you can swim out.
That's called the lockout chamber. And
we used to do that and uh, there's still,
we still do it,
but like it's a little bit more of a
specialized group that does that now.
But it used to just be a general thing
for good for if you were in the day and
he would do that.
And I mean it can definitely cause
you're in there with equipment as long a
while it would take a long time to get
ahold of seal squad out. Like what?
Like what's a wild boy? You'd be,
you'd be in that little chamber, uh,
for probably 15 minutes at a time.
But here's the thing, you're in there,
there's two major situations going on.
Number one, you're not just in there,
you're in there with like
one or two other guys. Yeah.
But you're also sitting there with
equipment, so got bags of weapons,
waterproof weapons. You actually
have your boats in there and there.
So it's all tight and here's,
here's what would really freak out.
So the water starts to fill,
it starts to fill up,
and then as it's filling up,
it gets to a point where
you got to keep it equal as,
and you're using these
little pressure valves. One,
you basically crank a valve that
pushes air into the chamber,
and so that pushes the water down.
If you're not good,
then you're going to mess up the pressure.
And it's called losing the bubble cause
there's a bubble of air that you're just
sitting there breathing.
If you don't equalize the pressure,
well then that bubble of just keeps
going up and then you lose the bubble.
The bubble is gone,
which I think is where the w that's what
I always thought. Losing the bubble.
And you've heard that term, right?
No. Okay. When someone says, oh,
he's losing the bubble. You've never
heard that before? No. Well, we would say,
and I've heard it, I've heard a civilian
say it too, so I'm pretty sure that it's,
yeah, but I think that that's
where it came from. It's like, Oh,
you're losing the bubble.
And I've been in the chamber when someone
lost the bubble and I remember I was
telling the guy, I was like,
Hey, you're losing the bubble,
you're losing the bubble. He wasn't
about, and then I'm underwater.
And then you've got to find the,
you've got to find the octopus,
which is the regulator of which you have,
you have air tanks just in there,
like compressed air tanks,
like scuba tanks that are strapped to
the wall just in case someone loses the
bubble.
But did you got to find,
they've got a chem light on a
red cam lights and you just dig,
dig around and go and grab the red cow.
Might you find your thing,
you start breathing and you find the
valve and you crank it and then the bubble
comes back. But yeah, you,
if you're claustrophobic in that situation
is going to be problematic. Big. Huge.
Yeah. Cause it's just the expression
on your face at this time.
She tells me that you would not, how
big was it? How big is the chambers?
It's smaller than the area that
you and I are sitting, right? Yeah.
Yeah. So my Mri for my
Bicep, I had to go like this,
like my hand up in the air.
Well you know,
I'm laying down so it's not up in the
air, but like, so you're not laying,
laying regular, one hand is up. Okay.
And for 15 minutes in that
little teeny tiny tube,
like how you're saying I
could lay on my bed like that.
They sedate you or anything.
You just dealt with it? Yeah.
This is how had a few Mris in my time,
but I just relaxed her, went in there,
no big deal. I didn't lose the bubble. I
do. No, no, no, no. The thing is I did it.
Well, here's the thing. So this is
what I really admitted to myself. Okay.
I have like a little, um,
sensitivity to it. Um, he's like,
okay, you got to put your arm up cause
it, you know, and you can't move.
So I'm thinking, man, I can just
lay it on my bed like this all day.
I'll sleep like that,
you know,
but why am I super like
nervous about this?
So I go in and he's putting me in and I
feel my heart just started beating real
fast, like full on. I'm
like, oh man. But um,
but I mentally push through it like the
kind of, I feel like not even a minute,
but maybe like 30, 45 seconds.
I'm like, ah, you know,
watch guys cave diving.
Like what do you mean?
No? Yes, yes, yes. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. We're done underwater.
But it's an underwater cave.
Yeah. And you're diving that can
get a little tight. Yeah. So, and I,
we um,
I'm quiet.
It was a place called the blue room
and it's that, and here's the thing.
So it's basically a cave. You walk up this
mountain maybe like, I don't know, 50,
50 yards, maybe up a mountain.
And you go, well, no,
no, the mountain is huge. You just
walked up 50 hours. Then there's a cake.
That's where the cave is and you're going
in the cave and depending on, you know,
how much it rained or whatever, there's
a little lake in the caves. Really cool.
We used to always go at the back of
the cave is a little teeny tiny hole,
teeny tiny pool. If the water's
too high and it covers that whole,
it's still a hole, but it's,
you got to go under water.
So at the end of that it basically,
that whole is a hallway that you swim
through. You can't touch the bottom.
It's like you swim through this little
hallway and it goes and it curves.
This is maybe maybe a 2020
yards day and not 20 that's,
that's you know, maybe
10 in the dark though.
And the only light is glowing,
bright blue light that the water creates
from the sun that shines in the water
and kind of reflects up. It's
really, it's really nice. But yeah,
if you have an issue with that,
especially if the other side, what do you,
it's a big room it now that's
another thing. Open to the light.
The light from the water
lights up the room. So it's,
it's, yeah, it's really weird.
That's why you kind of go cause
it's really awesome. The thing is,
there's nothing to hold on
to your treading water in
that room. So it's like, oh,
the rum room is deep water. Yeah. You
get in touch. It's a huge lake in there,
you know, so you can't touch
the bottom at all. And um,
but if the water level is high
enough where that cave or the,
the hallway we'll call it, it's like this,
you know, where you can just barely to,
it gets like, oh, this is kind
of nerve wracking for sure.
But sometimes it's real low and
it's cool you just swim through.
But if it's like your first time or you
have a little bit of Claustrophobia in
water like that, you'll,
it'll jam you up for sure.
But I never had a problem with Alan.
It's that,
it's what you said when you
know you can't move. Yeah.
But if you know you can move so you
can just stay there. It's weird.
It's like a psychological
thing, you know? Yeah, no,
but yeah, it's, you know,
I get that every once in a while on
the plane to the restraint machine.
So I guess that would be really effective
against some people that have a little
claustrophobia or they,
the thing is though,
okay, let's say all of these
methods are bad, right?
Let's say all these methods of reform are
bad. I feel good about saying that. Yes.
Okay. And then you say, okay, if I
was in that situation, I do everything
I could to get out of the scenario where
like okay I got arrested and I got put
in there straight machine and I got the
beat with a paddle and I got all those
things happen.
We get,
so you know what I'm going to do is try
and trying to stay clean a little bit.
Right. Get on, maybe get on a little bit
of a of a path. A better path. Yes sir.
It didn't work at all at
all. He didn't care. Yeah.
Well it kind of makes
sense that like when,
what did he say and went after the
snorting pole or whatever. Like Whoa,
you just fill out the hatred and murder
in your mind. Yeah. That seems like,
cause even the claustrophobia thing
on the, on the, what's that called,
the restraints situation.
Four hours every like every session,
all day.
You know,
like after awhile you're like you're
going to get used to that or you're going
to go so nuts that you're just going to
faint or I dunno, something like that.
Either way there's a part of your
mind I would think. I don't know.
That's just what it feels
like listening to it.
I feel like I would just
be so nuts at the end.
Like oh like I wouldn't care
about that restraint thing.
I would just care about like
murdering person or something.
I could see how that could go. Yeah. I
mean I personally wouldn't go that way.
I'll probably try not to go there
anymore, but that's just me. Yeah.
So maybe as a reform or if you cross
the line and you make someone snap,
now you're no longer being productive.
This is true with your kids then.
Maybe you haven't experienced this yet,
but you can like push your kids
to a point where they don't care.
Like yeah,
I'll take this away.
I'll take this away and then all of a
sudden they go, I don't care. Take it.
They throw their tour. You know
the tours that you're threatening,
they throw it at you.
Take it,
remember the breakfast club.
Remember that movie? I do remember,
I remember that Guy John Bender, what it
was Israel, I forget the actor's name,
but anyway,
I'm just trying to play bender is his
name and he's like guys which carry the
bad guy, the bad kid. Okay. And he's
really, and he's like, um, he's like, hey,
did Barry Manilow radio or did you
would read very mental. It was wardrobe.
And he's like, I'll give you the answer
to that, uh, next Saturday saying like,
you got another detention,
you're next day. And then,
then he says something else.
He goes, then you get another
Saturday. And he's like,
well, I'm free though. Soda.
You know, he did that. He was after,
I was like, I don't care. He's like,
and then he's holding up the horn,
two months vendor, I got two months.
Those good, a good part there. So
yes, you can't push it too far.
And obviously from a
leadership perspective,
we'll just go for a little
leadership perspectives here.
There are things you can do to the
people that work for you where they won't
care anymore. Yeah, and
now you, now you're done.
You have, you've lost control.
You've lost control over them,
so don't do that.
He talks about this electric,
electric shock to they
called the hummingbird first,
an ordinary steel bathtub with in which
four or five inches of ice cold water.
The victim is laid down in
there and chained hand and foot.
Then the chief torture enters the scene.
He's dressed in ordinary
clothes and old and
has only a rubber slicker and a pair of
rubber gloves on his hands and his hands.
He holds a common sponge.
The sponge is connected to
electric battery by wires.
The switch is turned on and the
torture advances on the victim.
He first begins on the soles of the
feet by gently rubbing the charge sponge
there and then gradually working his way
up to the body and to the head of the
sensations of to the victim or that
there seems to be millions of red hot
needles sticking into them.
The agony is intense two or three minutes
and the victim is ready for the grave
or the madhouse.
Yet there is not a single mark
or bruise on his whole body.
A physician stands beside this is sick.
The physician stands beside the victim
and every few seconds feels the pulse and
examines him.
When he judges that the victim is
exactly on the verge of madness or death,
he gives the signal to switch off the
current than the victim is thrown into a
cell where he left for
a few days or weeks.
Yeah, that's weird. The sponge,
how they put the sponge there
like on lethal weapon one he got,
he got rigs with that mirror
and I remember that's what
it made me think of when
you had the, the sponges and he's in
the shower. I'll tie it up like that.
He keeps like hitting him. He hit
him again. Yeah, those sponges.
I wonder what that that's about though.
The sponge, it conducts electricity,
water,
water conducts the direct mark.
It's just hitting you with like
a big shock pillow of shock.
Uh, continues on. He gets it,
eventually gets out of that prison and
any actually broke out of that prison.
And then he's now he's just
on like full crime mode.
I don't even know what goes beyond crime
mode, but just full stealing, raping,
murdering swindling.
He steals enough money.
He works on a bunch of different boats
and eventually steels enough money to buy
a yacht.
So he's bought a yacht and I
don't know how big the yacht was,
but it wasn't small.
And here we go back to the look on my
yard. I had quarters for five people,
but I was alone for a while.
Then I figured it would be a good plan
to hire a few sailors to work for me,
get them out on my yacht, get them
drunk, commits sodomy on them,
robbed them and killed them.
This I done every day or two.
I would get plenty of blues,
booze by robbing other yachts there.
The Barbara too was one of them. I robbed
her. Does nurse, so others around there.
I was hitting the booze pretty
hard myself at that time.
Every day or two I would go to New York
and hang around 25th street and size up
the sailors.
Whenever I saw a couple of who were
about my size and seem to have money,
I would hire them to work on my yacht.
I would always promise
them big pay and easy work.
What they got was something else.
I would take them and their clothes and
gear out to my yacht at city island.
There we would go and whine and dine and
when we, when they were drunk enough,
I would go to bed or they would go to bed.
When they were asleep,
I would get my 45 Colt
automatic army pistol.
This I stole from Mr [inaudible]
House and blow their brains out.
Then it would take out a rope and tie a
rock on them and put them into my robot.
Rowboat,
rolled them out in the main channel
about one mile and drop him overboard.
They are there yet 10 of them.
I worked at racket for about three weeks.
We eventually gets on another ship,
loses that kind of gets
people are suspect. He goes, gets
on a ship to Europe from Europe.
He goes to Africa in Africa.
He buys a girl.
I paid a big price for her.
I bought her from her mother and
father for about $8 in American money.
The reason I paid such a big price for
hers was because she was a virgin. Yeah,
so she said she was
about 11 or 12 years old.
I took her to my shack the first night
and took her back to her father's and
shack.
The next I demanded my money back because
they had deceived me by saying the
girl was a virgin.
I didn't get my money back,
but they gave me another younger girl.
This girl was about eight years old.
I took her to my shack and
maybe she was a virgin,
but it didn't look like it to me.
I took her back and quit looking for
any more virgin. I look for a boy.
I found one.
He was our table waiter.
I educated him into the art of sodomy
as practiced by civilized people,
but he was only a savage and didn't
appreciate the benefits of civilization.
He told my boss and the boss man
fired me quick, but before he did,
I licked the hell out of them.
The boy,
11 or 12 came bombing. Another boy
about 11 or 12 came bumming around.
He was looking for something.
He found it too.
I took him out to a gravel pit about a
quarter mile from the main camp of the
sing clear oil company.
I left him there,
but first I committed sodomy
on him and then kill them.
His brains were coming out of his ears
when I left him and he will never be any
debtor.
He is still there.
He ends up murdering another
six people in Africa on a boat.
He chartered a canoe and then kills
everyone in it and then signs onto a ship
that's heading back to New York.
That was the summer of 1922 he arrives
back in America back to the book in Salem,
Massachusetts.
I'm murdered in 11 or 12 year old boy
by beating his brains out with a rock.
I tried a little sodomy on him first I
left him laying there with his brains
coming out of his ears.
Went down towards New York robbing and
hell raising as I came in January or
February of 1923 I got a job as a watchman
at two 20 Yonkers avenue, Yonkers,
New York.
While there I met a young boy of 14 or
15 or his name was George and whose home
was in was an is in Yonkers. I started
to teach him the fine art of sodomy,
but he had, but I found he had been
taught about it all and he liked it fine.
I kept him with me until I left that
job of night in April of 1923 the kid,
George got scared and I let him go
home to Yonkers. When he got there,
he told the police all he knew about me,
which wasn't much,
but it was enough for the
cops to come looking for me.
They caught me and my yacht at Nyack,
they took me boat and all
my plunger to Yonkers jail.
They're charged me with sodomy, burglary,
robbery and trying to break jail there.
Yeah,
in and out again a few days.
He gets out.
A few days later I went to new
haven where I killed another boy.
I committed a little more sodomy on him
and then tied his belt around his neck
and strangled him,
picked him up where he was when he was
dead and through his body over behind
some bushes.
Eventually he does his time.
He gets trial for the, uh,
sodomy burglary and robbery,
pleads guilty and immediately
given the limit of the law,
five years at once I was sent to sing
sing and then from sing sing he gets sent
to another prison called Dan and Mora,
which is a notorious,
notorious prison,
says in the book of all the prisons,
Dana Maura was the one and only
designed specifically to punish.
And so now this gets really interesting
because he's in this really bad prison
does, and there's a description that's
not from him that's just part of the book,
part of the information in the book,
talking about Dana Maura
and how bad it is there.
And then he's done a whole this heinous,
I mean,
just heinous acts that he should be
killed for it over and over again.
And here he is. Um, going back to
the book, I attempted to escape.
I failed in my attempt, but in doing so,
I fell about 30 feet to a concrete walk,
breaking both my ankles, both
my legs, fracturing my spine,
and rupturing myself in this condition,
I was carried to the prison hospital where
I leave for five days and was carried
out and dumped into a cell without any
medical or surgical attention, whatever.
My broken bones were not set, my ankles
and legs were not put into a cast.
In fact, nothing was done except
give me a bottle of Lindemann,
which I would have done,
which would have done no good if I
had been able to rub it on myself.
The doctor never came near me and no one
else was allowed to do anything for me
in that condition. I was left for
eight months. At the end of the time,
the bones had knitted together. I could
stagger around on a pair of crutches,
so it's like he's complaining
about his maltreatment, right?
I got injured and they didn't take
care of me. It's like, hey bro.
Yeah,
you don't get any good treatment.
At the end of 14 months of constant agony,
I was taken to the hospital where I was
operated on for my rupture and one of my
testicles was cut out five
days after my operation.
I tried to see if my sexual
organs were still in good order.
I got caught trying to commit
sodomy on another prisoner for that.
I was thrown out of the hospital and
dumped into a cell where I suffered more
agony for many months, always in pain,
never a civil answer from anyone.
Always a smaller a cursor
allying hypocritical promise,
which was never kept crawling around
like a snake with a broken back seething
with hatred and a lust for revenge.
Five years of my life of this kind.
Okay.
The last two years and four months
confined in isolation with nothing to do
except brood upon what
I thought the wrong,
what I fought was the wrongs
that had been done to me,
not allowed to receive letters
or visits from friends.
When the prison inspectors came to
investigate conditions and complaints,
they were told I was a degenerate,
that I suffered from delusions,
that I was insane.
So they would pay no attention to me
or anything that I or anyone else ever
complained of.
Okay.
This went on for all of my five
years and the more they misused me,
the more I was filled with the
spirit of hatred and revenge.
I was so full of hate that there was no
room in me for such feelings as love,
pity, kindness, or honor or
decency. I hated everyone. I saw,
uh,
again,
it's a guy that t he only sees the
pain that's been caused to him,
but apparently doesn't see any of the
pain that he's caused. Anybody else?
Zero. Empathy, zero.
Then it's sort of,
could it seem,
or could it happen like this
with him where, you know,
when he's young he gets beat down.
[inaudible] obviously not
shown much affection. That's,
that's the assumption obviously, but
beat down. So now he has this hatred,
so now he inflicts pain on
quote Unquote Others. Mm. Right.
Because of the hatred he has or whatever.
So it's kind of like him kind
of what getting event for sure.
Lack of a better term. So he gets even
and then he gets punished for that. Right.
Obviously because he can't commit
crimes like that. So he gets punished.
So now he thinks it's an uneven now, hey,
you know? Yeah. It's just the feeling.
He's not like, yes. So now he's like, oh,
now that now me being punished
for what I did by the way,
but me being punished has given me
even more hate. Now I got to, you know,
seek vengeance for that.
Then he does it.
Then of course he gets and he just keeps
doing it. So it's like this cycle. Well,
the,
there's another cycle here and the cycle
is he's blaming everyone else for the
situation that isn't blaming everyone
and at a certain point, sure,
let's,
let's blame that first state penitentiary
that he was in when he was a kid.
The state school let, let's put some
blame on them. Okay. Yeah. But you got
out of that and you had another
opportunity to get on the right path and,
and then you, what do you do? You just
blame, blame, blame, blame, blame.
And the more you're blaming other people,
do you put yourself into a downward spiral
that he's never going to get out of,
obviously. Yeah, they need,
now he's blaming. He blames
the whole human race. I mean,
let's,
it's,
it's real easy just to sorta s he only
writes about it for three sentences,
but like, oh, oh,
in new haven I raped and murdered
an 11 year old boy. Yeah. Like,
no, you don't get any mercy now. And you
can't blame anyone else for doing that.
That's no one else's fault you did that.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
But in his mind, the o for shake,
you know how like when you hate,
let's say you flick your friend
on the head joking around, right?
You flip them on the head,
you don't care.
Then your friends liked to be
interested in friends, like, hey,
that was kind of heart, you know, so,
so he'd like flicks you an escalation
for a hard and you're like, Hey,
I did flick you on the head that
hard. So you smack them, you know?
And it turns into this big fight and
who's who's, who's to blame, right? Yeah.
Both guys feel like, Hey,
I flick y'all just joking.
You didn't have to flick me that hard.
The other guy like,
why'd you flick me in the first
place? You don't kind of thing. So,
and I'm not saying that
that's what happened,
but in his mind that's probably
what it feels like. Oh for sure.
That's what it feels like for sure.
That's what it feels like.
And we all can feel like that at
one time or another. We think, oh,
it's this person's fault, it's that
person's fault. It's my parents.
It's the school system.
It's the whatever. It's
society. Yeah, right.
It's society.
Yeah.
It's every other human being like
that's where he's at right now.
He hated everyone I saw.
Yeah. That's where he's at.
It's like he's the victim and he's the
victim and just listened to. I mean,
it's so clear when he's talking about
all these medical problems that he,
he's the victim.
He's the victim.
Whereas if he would've just swapped
his attitude early on and said, okay,
what about what's happening right
now? Even the first, why did he,
why did he get sent to the
state penitentiary or to
the state school system?
Because he stole a gun,
ran away,
but it ripped it ripped off a family of
their stuff. Like, Oh, if you do that,
you go to prison. But he didn't see that
this is fault. That wasn't his fault.
He did that because he was living
in a bad home. It's like, okay,
at some point you have to take ownership
of what's going on in your world and
you can't just continually blame
other people. If you do eventually,
you know who's at fault,
everyone in the world, but you.
Yeah.
It's true, so let's not get
there. I'll tell you what,
it was a pretty good transition
for when I joined the navy.
That's one thing that I've talked
about how when I joined the navy tech,
a clean slate,
you know what I mean?
Like it doesn't matter what you did and
that was a really positive thing for me
because all of a sudden,
and it's a very cause and effect when
you're going through like Navy boot camp
or any kind of boot camp,
any kind of military indoctrination,
if you don't do what you're supposed
to do, you get punished for it.
If you do what you're supposed to do,
you either a don't get punished at a
minimum or you get some type of reward and
it's all set up that way purposely,
but it's very easy.
It was very easy for me to comprehend
as an 18 year old kid going, Oh,
if I, if I do this right,
I will be rewarded.
If I do this wrong,
I will be punished.
This is on me and then what you read.
Then the next thing that they build
on top of that is if I let my team do
something wrong,
we will all get punished.
If we do things correctly.
We will receive at a minimum,
no punishment and possibly
some type of reward.
It was very easy for me to assemble
those pieces in my young brain.
And let's face it,
when you're 18 years old,
I mean my brain wasn't all that develops,
right?
I mean like physiologically speaking,
the Ma,
like what does it,
the male frontal cortex isn't fully
formed until they're like 25 right?
Didn't you tell me that?
Yes. Yeah, so there you go.
So there I was 18 and I yet was able
to figure out, okay, wait a second,
if I do this, it's on
me. If I get punished,
it's my fault. If our team gets
punished and, and again, that's a,
that's a little jump there to kind of
bring you through that little phase of
like, okay, we get, now you're
responsible for you. You understand that.
And once you understand,
that's like, okay, now you're
responsible for your team.
And some people don't make
that transition. Some people,
you know within the team,
oh, it wasn't my fault. He
was Jimmy's fault. Right.
And as you stay in the military
longer or as you go in any workforce,
eventually you realize, okay, if we
don't, if I don't work as a team,
we're all going to get punished.
So I needed help. The team,
he's not learning any of this.
That helped me was awful.
Back to the book and my whole mind was
bent on figuring out ways to annoy and
punish my enemies and everybody
was my enemy. I had no friends.
That was the frame of mind I was in when
my five years was up and I was turned
loose to go anywhere I wanted to go.
My intention was to rob
rape and kill everybody.
I could anybody and everybody,
and he goes through these long kind
of plans of putting bombs in inside of
tunnels and and w how to get a gas mask
and he's be used poison gas and he's
going to steal so much
money and then with this,
with this bunch of money that he was
going to get from robbing all these people
in in these plot that he has with that,
he says with unlimited funds in my hands,
I then intended to steal millions of
dollars and killed millions of people.
This I intended to do by starting
a war between England and the USA.
Sounds fantastic. All right, but
I'm positive he could have done it.
He goes through his whole plot of
how he was going to make that happen.
He was going to bomb a British
ship that was, you know,
like here peacefully bomb it and
make it look like America did it when
diplomatic relationship for we're already
strained. That was his plant. Hmm.
That's crazy. I used to spend
all my time for, you're not high.
Could murder the most people with
the least harm and expense to myself.
And I finally thought of a way to kill
off the whole town. Men, women, children,
and even cats and dogs.
And he goes through another big
plan about using arsenic and,
and dead hogs and put
them in the water swim.
He goes through like detailed plants,
okay.
Now this was some interesting,
his perception of what it was
like. He's back in jail again. Um,
and I forget what for this time,
but for all this crap that
he's doing all the time,
all these crimes he's committing back to
the book of the underworld code is very
simple. It is never squeal.
Don't be a stool pigeon.
A rat on informer. All crooks want
everybody else to believe that they are.
Square cops are the same.
They all wish everybody else to
think they act from principle.
They are always telling everyone they
meet about how much principal they have.
It is against their
principal to do this or that.
The queer part of it is that they
not only want others to believe this,
but they believe it themselves.
But the real truth of the matter is
that they deceive themselves and mistake
policy for principle,
when crooks are square with anyone,
it is because it is for their own interest
to be so it is good policy when it
ceases to be in their own interest
to square with another one,
then it becomes time to change their
tactics and they aren't slowing doing it
either. It makes no difference
to them who they snitch on,
no matter if they had been loyal to
each other through a whole lifetime as
partners and friends,
no matter if they send their friends
to prison or to hell by way of rope or
chair,
that cuts no ice.
They are looking out for
their own precious skins.
No, this is a guy also that
doesn't trust anybody. So,
and that's actually what he said.
I mean certainly that's theirs.
You can't say that about it.
You can say that about a lot of people,
but there's all kinds of
criminals that never give up.
The never, never given him his
names, never rat on anybody else.
And they get the book thrown
at him and they take it back.
The book every child has,
this is interesting.
Every child has some criminal tendencies.
It is your place to correct those traits
and teach them the right way to live
while they are young and they're minds
are forming. Then when they do the reach,
the age of reason and action, it will
be quite natural for them to live clean,
upright, honorable lives. In that way,
you will stop crime at its
source before it begins
as a child,
a child is very easily led.
Any child of properly taught will
live the way he is taught to live.
All criminals are merely
overgrown children.
It is in your hands to
make us or break us.
We buy our own efforts are failures in
life simply because we don't know any
better. We don't know how to
live decent, upright lives.
Hereditary heredity has very little
to do with the shaping of our lives.
The main causes of why we are what we
are is because of our improper teaching,
lack of knowledge and our environment.
Every man's philosophy is
colored by his environment.
If you don't want us to rob rape and
murder you than it is your place to see
that the mental and moral
misfits are properly taught,
a sufficient amount of useful insensible
knowledge to put their proper to and
put into the proper environment where
they can be best fitted to exist in life.
So there you go. The nature,
nurture, argument, pans, Ram, all,
all nurture. It's all
how you're raised. Hmm.
It goes on.
I was born a normal human being.
My parents were ignorant and through
their improper teachings and improper
environment, I was gradually led
into the wrong way of living.
Little by little from Brat,
bad to worse.
I was sent to reform school at
age 11 from that day to this,
all of my life has been lived
among moral and mental misfits.
All my associates, all my
surroundings, the atmosphere of deceit,
treachery brutality,
degeneracy,
hypocrisy and everything that
is bad and nothing that is good.
It is unnatural that I
should have absorbed these
things and I've become what I
am today. A treacherous,
degenerate, brutal, savage,
human devoid of all decent feeling.
Absolutely. Without conscience,
moral pity,
sympathy principal,
or any single good trait.
Why am I what I am?
I'll tell you why I did
not make myself what I am.
Others had the making of me
everyone else's fault,
and I'm not in the power to control it.
Right?
I mean,
at this point he recognizes what he is,
but he doesn't make any effort
to reform himself. Yeah. Yeah.
It's kind of those two, like even
with extreme ownership, right?
When you're working with a team,
when you say it's easy to blame others
and especially when it is their fault at
certain times, it's like their fault
that this happened to, that happened.
It's like a philosophy,
right? It's like an approach.
It's a certain approach where
you say, okay, you know,
whatever their fault that
this happened or whatever.
It's really hard to up with a situation
when you're a leader of a
team and it's the teams fault.
Yeah.
I haven't been able to come up
with one lately and to say it's,
maybe you can, that's not what I'm
saying. What I'm saying is it is,
well, okay, we'll go with this
guy. Oh, guidance from a guy
on Twitter. Yeah. He said,
hey man,
why are you giving all this
hate to machine gunners
shooting outside their field
of fire? Because I use that
example a lot. Yeah. Hey,
the machine gunner shoots off
the outside of his field of fire.
That's the machine gunners fault,
right? No. And I said, dude, hey man,
I don't hate machine gunners.
I hate the officer's that blame the
machine gunner when the machine gunner
doesn't know where he's supposed to be
shooting that thought machine gunners
fault. That's your fault boss. Yeah.
So so continue on about the situation
trying to refer to,
so I,
this is like a typical little thing that
I'll hear from people. It's like wow,
you know, sometimes I got to take
ownership even though it's really,
that's what you think you're wrong.
Yeah, no, no raw. Okay. Gag. I dig it.
But cause because right now I'm not
saying about whose fault it is and that's
not, that's not the point I'm trying
to make. It's more that he's right.
It is because of them.
Like they or the way his parents raised
him did cause him to be like this.
It caused him to be like this
and it cause him to be hit.
Like it didn't like his parents
raising them didn't make him, you know,
sodomized that kid or whatever. He
didn't, they didn't make him do it,
but their rate of the way they raised
him caused him just cause it effect
straight up caused him to be
like that quote unquote no,
it's his fault. Yes. It's his fault that
he's doing all these things, you know,
cause you can just not,
you can not do it.
That's possible to just not do it
that day or add or whatever. So yeah.
As far as fault and blaming, yes. Okay.
You're going Sam Harris Freewill on me.
Well see the thing is,
I mean I guess what I'm saying is like
if you don't grow into lack of freewill
yeah. Lack of freewill.
No, well not necessarily.
I'm just basically isolating the blaming
part of it and then the cause and
effect part of it, you know,
kind of thing. Because in
that case he's, he's right.
Like there what he's saying is correct.
As long as he's not saying and it's their
fault and it's not my fault. I'm not,
you know who he is saying that?
Yes. Okay, so, so push that aside.
He's writing on sentence myself.
What I am.
Others had the making of me.
It's everyone else's fault that I'm
like this. Yeah, that's, that's,
that's not extreme on a shit right there.
No,
but oh gold cause an effect on them.
Here's my point.
Here's my point because this is
not, this is a gray area, right?
We're in a gray area. Here's
the problem. If he looks at it,
if he only lens that he
looks at it through is this
is everyone else's fault and
he's not to blame, then guess what?
He's not going to make any changes.
If he had a little bit, if he just
looked at the situation and said,
you know what?
All these happened,
but some of this is because of me.
Yeah.
Some of this is because the actions
that I've taken and I can now change my
behavior so I don't stay in this
mode of operating right now.
That's the difference. Yeah,
and he never makes that change.
He never makes that that different.
He never sees it that way.
The only thing he sees is that it's
everyone else's fault and when you,
this is the thing he goes, you can
see it gradually increases. He's,
he's going from like, oh I just hate
this teachers and and I just hate them,
the wardens and eventually
he hates everybody cause
it's everyone else's fault.
Even people he doesn't even know because
they're a member of the human race.
He hates them.
Yeah.
That's why personal responsibility, so
important to teach to kids. Yes sir.
It is so important to teach the kids
and that's one thing I think I learned.
I mean obviously I've got
some of it from my parents,
but it was really crystal clear when I
came when I came in the military because
it's black and white that
the gray area is gone.
When you go through some kind of military
indoctrination, the gray area is gone.
You mess this up, it's your fault. You're
going to get punished for it. Yeah.
We still get guys right that oh sure.
For sure.
Drill sergeant is writing me
or whatever or you know, Bill,
he should have done this. Jones should
have done that. Right? It's like okay,
but it doesn't matter. Sure. Yeah.
Okay. The man, does it matter
back to the book,
I have only a little knowledge,
but I have as much intelligence as the
average person and I know I was taught
wrong. I could have been taught
properly and if I had been,
I sure feel I would led a far
different life than I have done.
You are to blame more so
than I just straight up you.
He's talking to us, talking to her
general human, the race of human beings.
That's my belief.
If you are going to go on teaching
others as you have taught me,
then you must suffer the same as I.
Uh,
here we go.
He is at this point on trial
and this is from like a,
I think this is one of the ones from
a newspaper clipping or report, but
it's another part. This is so
this isn't pants, Rams Journal.
This is some of the additional information
back to the book on the stand pan.
Drums, eyes slid toward the table
where his pistol and burglar tools lay.
Prosecutor Collins whispered to an
assistant who hurried over and remove the
exhibits to a safer place.
The arms of the witness chair
disappeared under pans, rams,
huge hands as he faced the jury
ignoring everyone else in the courtroom,
you people got me here charged with
housebreaking in larceny. I'm guilty.
I broken and I stole what I didn't steal.
I smashed. If the owner had come home,
I would have knocked his
brains out. Pans, rems,
eyes took on this, uh, strange
depth as he watched the jury.
There's something else you ought to
know while you were trying me here,
I was trying all of you too.
I've found you guilty.
Some of you I've executed. If I
live, I'll execute some more of you.
I hate the whole human race.
He said evenly,
a juror gasped. Pans, Ramsay.
Round heads suddenly swung
toward the prosecutor who
looked alert and suspicious.
You think I'm playing crazy, don't
you? I'm not. I know right from wrong.
No delusions. I don't hear
anything. You don't care.
My conscience doesn't bother me.
I have no conscience.
I believe the whole human race should
be exterminated. I'll do my best to do,
do it.
Every chance I get
the courtroom was now numb as pans.
Ram turned to the doors once more.
Now I've done my duty.
You do yours.
So
he gets a long prison sentence
and when he gets into prison,
he actually kills a, uh, one of the
civilian workers. They're in prison.
Like a guy that just, is it like a
maintenance guy who runs the laundry and
he's
has a beef and kills him.
And
this is where we start.
This isn't one of the letters.
So I talked about the Guy
Henry lessor who was a garden,
one of the prisons he was in who formed
a relationship with him when he actually
says a couple of times that this is the
only guy that like didn't try and take
some from, I think the whole
thing started off a game,
like a dollar to buy cigarettes
or whatever and no one,
according to him,
no one had ever done anything nice
for pan drowned in his whole life.
And this,
this garden was the first guy to do it.
So he develops a relationship with them
and so they go,
they write letters back and forth,
and here's the excerpt of one of
those many letters back to the book.
The real truth of the matter is that I
haven't the least desire to reform very
much.
The reserve reverse of that is true.
I would not reform if the front
gate was open right now and I was,
and if I was given $1
million when I stepped out,
I have no desire to do good or to be good.
I am just as mean now as I can be and the
only reason I am no worse is because I
lacked the power and the proper
opportunity for meanness.
If I had the power and the opportunities,
then I would soon show you
what real meanness was.
You overlook the fact that the law and
a great many people have been trying
their damnedest for 25 years to reform me.
I am tired of having
people try to reform me.
What I want to do is reform them and I
think the best way to reform them is to
put out of their misery.
It took me 36 years to be like I am now.
Then how do you figure that I could if I
wanted to change from black to white in
the twinkling of an eye?
Another letter,
same theme.
I have no desire to reform under such
conditions as would be required of me the
way the laws of this country are today.
I do not care to live any longer.
If I must live in prison,
I would far rather die and go to hell
if that's where people like me go after
death.
I've very thoroughly considered this
matter and I assure you now what I say is
the truth.
I've confessed 21 different cold blooded,
premeditated murders,
hundreds of cations of cases of arson,
burglaries, robberies,
rapes, and other crimes.
The law has by this time looked them
up and verify the truth of my various
confessions.
My philosophy of life is such that very
few people ever get and just so deeply
ingrained and burned into me that I don't
believe I could ever change my beliefs.
The things I've done to others,
the things that I have had done to me
by others and the things I have done to
them can never be forgotten or
forgiven either by me or others.
I can't forget and I won't forgive.
I couldn't if I wanted to.
The law is in the same fix.
My belief is that the life without
liberty is not worth having.
If a law won't kill me,
I shall kill myself.
I fully realize that I am not fit to live
among people in a civilized community.
I have no desire to do so.
If I had any choice in living any longer,
the only way I would consent to do so
would be to get clear out and away from
all civilized people.
I'm so set in my ways that I cannot adapt
myself to the ways of other people so
that the only way for me to do would
be to live by myself without any human
companionship.
Whatever.
He actually describes
this island that he's
kind of spent a little time on when he
was down in South America. Then he's like,
send me there if you wanted
to send me somewhere,
goes back.
So now he'd killed that other guy,
wonky the civilian and now he's
going to trial for that murder.
And this is a newspaper
report of that trial.
Back to the book,
the commission heard the hard boiled
giant tell of the fun which he received in
killing a man and there
isn't a man in this room.
I wouldn't kill the cruel visage steel
eyed man told the commission I mad plenty
mad. Now I don't believe
there's any good in any man.
I'd like to have the
opportunity to go weigh,
gain power and brains and then I'd
like to kill off the rest of the world.
The convict said,
okay.
Dr. Perry asked the giant if he believed
himself better than the rest of mankind.
Hell no was the reply.
I've checked up on myself lately and I
know that I'm probably worse than the
rest of you. I have no desire
to live. If you would hang me,
my troubles would be over
and I would be better. Yeah,
rough,
but don't you fear Hell Fire?
A member of the commission inquired.
You haven't been able to prove to me
that there is such a thing. Penn pans,
ram answered the man boasted in court of
killing 21 person's and vowed that when
his parents were his parents living,
he would kill them.
Quote for bringing me into the world.
Okay.
There are two things in this world that
count as powerful money and knowledge.
If I could get enough money, I would
buy brains because brains are for sale.
I could get a brainy chemist and I would
have them prepare me a lot of poison
gas and germs.
With these I would be able to
exterminate a great mass of human beings.
Then I would kill myself.
Society should build a great monument
because I have never propagated my kind.
So that's what his little excerpt
of what his trial was like. This,
you know, he was done. I
mean he just did not care.
Back to the book,
and this is the good book itself.
The court convened again the next morning
and the judge having been given no
alternative by the hard rural jury look
down at the defendant and pronounced him
guilty with no mention of lifesaving
phrase without capital punishment pans.
Ram had nothing to say
concerning the sentence.
Hopkins then ordered that he be remanded
with to the care of the warden at the
Federal Penitentiary Penitentiary at
Leavenworth there to be confined until the
fifth day of September when between the
hours of six and nine o'clock in the
morning, you shall be taken to some
suitable place within the confines of the
penitentiary and hanged
by the neck until dead.
The judge then announced
the 90 day interval to allow
for any bill of objection
and appeal before the defense attorney
could speak pans. Ram said swiftly.
I don't want any attorney to file
for a new trial or appeal anything.
I am satisfied with the verdict.
So while he's now on death row,
there's a like a delegation of people
that are against capital punishment and
they start fighting to
get them off death row.
Yeah.
And he writes them a letter and
here's a little part of that letter.
On February 1st,
1929 I began serving this sentence at
the u s penitentiary at 11 worth Kansas.
On June 20th,
1929 I murdered one man,
a civilian employee of the
prison by the name of warranty.
And at the same time and place I also
attempted to murder a dozen other both
guards and convicts.
The only reason I did not kill them
was also because I couldn't catch them.
If I give,
if I'm given another trial or if the
death sentence should be commuted to life
imprisonment either in
penitentiary or an insane asylum,
it will be against my will.
Okay.
And then he goes on to
try to explain to them,
cause he doesn't want them to think that
he's crazy because if he's crazy then
he's not, he's going to get it's insane
asylum or you know, reason of insanity.
Back to the book.
I shall try and convince you that
I am quite saying at this time,
I am at this time, 38 years
old, a big powerful man,
strong in both body and mind.
My physical fitness is not
as good as it once was,
but my mental facilities
are unimpaired in any way.
I've never used drugs of
any kind or any type. I am.
I am and always have been a
very moderate drinker of liquor,
practically a total abstainer.
I've never taken any disease of any kind
which would have the tendency to weaken
my intellect.
I have never been addicted to any habits
of sexual excesses of any kind over
which I didn't have
complete control of myself.
I choose to die here and now by being
hanged by the neck until I'm dead.
I prefer that I die that way and if I
have a soul and if that soul should burn
in hell for a million years still,
I prefer that to a lingering,
agonizing death in some prison dungeon
or a padded cell and a mad house.
I do not believe that being hanged by
the neck until dead is a barbaric or in
human punishment.
I look forward to to it as a real pleasure
and a big relief for me and not feel
bad or unhappy about it in any way
everyday since I received that sentence,
I've felt pretty good.
I feel good right now and I believe
that when my last hour comes,
I will dance out of my dungeon and onto
the scaffold with a smile on my face and
happiness in my heart.
Another reason why I believe that this
sentence should be carried out is because
I believe it is justice and I am
quite sincere when I say that.
This is the first and only time in my
life of battling with the law that I ever
did get justice from the law.
One other thing I am going to tell you
before I stopped this letter and that is
this,
the only thanks that you are your kind
will ever get from me for your efforts on
my behalf is that I wish you all had
one neck and then I had my hands on it.
Okay.
I would sure put you out of your misery.
Just the same as I've done
with numbers of other people.
Yeah.
I have no desire,
whatever to reform myself.
My only desires to reform
people who try to reform me,
and I believe that the only way to
do reform to people is to kill him.
My motto is rape a mall,
rob a mall and kill them all.
I am very truly yours.
Carl Pans Ram
another
letter,
I think it was the next to the last letter
that he wrote to Lesser Henry Lusher.
He says,
I had no choice about coming into this
world and nearly 38 nearly all of my 38
years in that have had very little to say
and do about how I should live my life.
People have driven me into
doing everything I've ever done.
Now, the time has come when I refuse
to be driven any further, so again,
I've just done,
I've only done what I've done because
of what other people have done to me.
That's not on me.
Zero responsibility.
Everything I've ever done is
because of other people ever,
ever.
It's a slippery slope that you just
tried to step on him for a couple minutes
ago. Yes, it is actually
in your thinking about it
[inaudible] aren't you?
Yeah,
but I'm not wrong because I'm
not talking about the blame.
I'm talking about cause and effect. But
here's the thing though, caused an effect.
It's kind of like that's easy to start
blaming. You know you got us this,
see what I'm saying?
Technically I want to split hairs,
but technically there's a difference.
Okay.
My point is if you have the Aetnas this,
I mean I work with people all the time
and this is the most important transition
that people make in their brain
is whether you're a business leader,
whether you're talking
about your personal life,
whether you're talking about the, the
family, whatever you're talking about,
the transition that you make from
doing what you're saying right now,
which is like, well, it's
actually their fault. They've,
that's in the back of your mind. Okay.
If that's in the back of your mind like,
okay, the problem is it grows.
Yeah. The problem is you use that.
The Prom is next thing, you know, it's
not just that their fault, it's this,
it's their fault.
And it's the other thing that's their
fault and it's the my team's fault.
And it's a, and I, it's
not my fault. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, just to be clear though,
that I'm not seeing the fault part of
it. The fault, the fault in the blaming,
that part of it literally
has nothing to do with it.
Are you saying caused an effect? There are
two different things. There's the look,
put it this way. Look, okay. And I
said, kind of say this as a joke where,
I dunno, let's say I did something
right and then I'd be like, well,
it's not my fault. It's, um, you know,
my parent's fault for having me. Oh,
but it's their fault. There
are actually, it's great.
My grandparents fault for having them. Oh
No, it's the, you know, my great grand,
you know,
and you start just blaming every little
factor that contributed to this result.
Every little factory. Right. Here's the,
so basically to kind of break
that apart, it's like, yeah,
if my parents didn't have me,
this wouldn't have happened.
It's true. It's true.
But the thing is you can't just start
point blame as far as assigning blame
goes. I'm not assigning
blame if I'm saying, Hey,
this is a factory or whatever as
unless I'm doing it as a joke.
You see what I'm saying?
Okay. So it's like, okay,
so if when you do cross the
line to start assigning blame,
that's when you can't be like,
okay,
it's everything else that you've
got to blame yourself. But it,
let's say you're not assigning blame,
you're just maybe analyzing it from an
objective perspective. So what I'm saying,
you can identify all kinds of causes,
all kinds of causes seem sane
and they're probably true. Okay.
But not having anything to do with
causing bleeding or, or assigning blame,
we're saying who's fault it is. Same.
Same check. Okay. It's just, uh,
another example of how like you or we,
whatever when I talked
to a lot of the time,
sometimes all you will take a scenario
and I'll just sort of marvel at different
working parts of this scenario. Like, oh,
isn't it interesting how this
is this and this is this,
but you could do this and
look at it this way too,
even though it has nothing to do with me,
you know?
And it has nothing to do with any kind
of actions to be taken or nothing like
that.
It's essentially just analyzing the
scenario and being interested in it versus
you, you always look at the scenario
like, okay, yeah, cool, that's cool.
You analyze it, but what
do you do? You know,
your attitude is really a real take
action kind of kind of approach.
So I think that's where I think
that's where we're getting some,
some misfires.
So what I'm saying,
you think that it's like I want to base
some action to be taken upon the way I'm
looking at it when it requires no action,
it's just the way to sort of look at it,
you know? But if you want to take action,
like, okay, so who do we blame? That's,
that's the beginning of taking
action in a way. Who Do we blame?
What do we got to fix?
Who Do we got to fix?
Whatever to move forward
to fix a situation, to, you
know, whatever. Rectify it.
Then you've got to be like,
okay,
I've got to identify the problem that I
can change. And then yeah, in that case,
then yeah, that problem's
going to be yourself. It's
the best way. And if it's not,
then you're not going to solve anything.
Yeah.
You just can't sit around and blame
people. Yeah. But does that make sense?
Maybe I don't recommend it. No.
Yeah, and that's the thing. Yeah.
And again, even that was saying,
I don't recommend it. That's like, that's
super indicative of just like, yeah,
you don't recommend that as
a problem solving technique.
That's a t that's an take
action approach right there.
See what I'm saying?
It's kind of like if we
came to a stoplight and then
the stop lights red and I'm
like, wow, isn't that red
stoplight? Super Nice. Like,
it's a beautiful color of red and
you're going to be like, yeah, like,
but it means to stop. So we're
stopped. I'm like, no, I know,
but isn't it kind of beautiful?
Then it turns green. Wow.
Isn't that a beautiful green light?
And you were like, yeah, but it's,
it means to go. And I'm like, cool.
But it's a pretty nice shade of green.
You see what I'm saying?
See what I'm saying? It's like
two different perspectives. Yeah.
And then of course he drove through
the green light and you know,
I had to go get after it. All
right, we'll leave that one at that.
All right.
Um,
obviously the attempts to save
Carl Pans Ram were ceased. And
here's how his life and according
to this book at Leavenworth,
the lights of the isolation that burned
into a pale gray dawn, September 5th,
when pants ram heard the distant
distant rattle of footsteps.
It was not quite six o'clock guard.
Bellard went over to the steel door
leading to an outer corridor and peered
through the small barred
window warden whites.
Voice was heard and the guard
turned a brass key in the lock.
The door swung open.
White entered the isolation at the head
of the procession of some 20 persons
including guards and newspaper reporters.
Immediately behind the warden was
Marshall McKeever of McKeever and the tall
government hang man carrying the
leather harness over one arm.
White stopped in front of pans,
rams cell.
The spectators press themselves discretely
against the opposite wall. It's pans.
Ram faced them searching through
the wire mesh with his hostile eyes.
Okay?
He saw two men in clerical garb on the
fringes of the crowd in a once began to
roar it white.
Okay.
Are there any Bible backed
cock suckers in here?
I thought you might change your mind.
White apologized.
These gentlemen came along. Way
To offer you comfort. Get 'em out.
Shouted Pants, Ram. I
don't mind being hanged,
but I don't need any Bible
back to hypocrites around
me. Run them out, warden,
or you'll have one hell of a
time getting me out of this cell.
Every man I get a hand on
his going to the hospital.
Okay.
White new pans.
Ram was within a condemned
man's traditional rights
regarding witnesses of his
own execution.
Yeah.
The disappointed clergy men were
escorted out. All right, pants. Ram said.
Let's get going.
What are we stalling for?
Okay.
White motions.
The guards,
a newsman to proceed to the exercise
yard is Bollard opened pants,
ram sell pans.
Ram helped as escorts faster
the fast and the leather corset.
Anything you want to say? Ask The
hangmen. Fumbling with a strap pans.
Ram snapped impatiently. Yes.
Hurried up. You. Who's your bastard?
I could hang a dozen men
while you're fooling around.
Okay.
In the yard, the newsman took hurried
notes. The scaffold looked strange.
Somehow unexpected.
Do glistened on the boards that had
the raw temporary look of a structure
erected for a county fair.
Yeah.
In less than a minute, the backdoor
of the isolation opened and pans.
Ram was emerged between
Ballard and the hang man pans.
Ram was almost running ahead, half
dragging the taller, his taller escorts,
white and the Marshall Hurry behind,
trailed by officer's trying
to look dignified as they ran.
Okay.
And the confusion the spectators parted
into two lines as they per session.
As the procession raised pell
mell and their direction pans,
rams face was rigid and look straight
ahead. His eyes fixed on the rope.
Okay.
Only at the foot of the stairs did he
seem to notice the transfixed onlookers.
He paused,
look slowly around and spat twice
that his face was forward again.
Everyone's nostrils inhaled the sweet
smell of new oak and hemp and everyone's
eyes followed him up the 13 steps
which he felt with his feet.
He hurried up the gallows as toward the
gate pulling Ballard and the hang man
with him.
Reporters who had witnessed
this event were surprised by it.
Swiftness and their accounts were in
conflict as to the time and exact detail.
Okay.
There was uncertainty as to whether pans,
Ram and been able to spit on the
executioner as he had promised.
He would the reporter's notebooks hide
hung limp during the swift adjustment of
the rope.
The exploding sound of the opening doors
and the swift downward stroke of the
body.
Yeah.
Later they recalled the mist which had
settled on the yard and the indistinct
figures of guards watching
from a tower on the wall.
The prison had been quiet.
The first bell was not yet
scheduled to ring for an hour.
Reporters had left the same way.
They came in and were relieved to
find themselves outside the walls.
Records of official entry regarding
the death of Carl Pans, Ram, our brief,
Dr Justin Kay Fuller,
one of the two doctors and attendants
step forward and to the stretch body
underneath the gallows,
placed a stethoscope gently on
the chest and palputated the neck.
Yeah.
Later he dictated his
report to a prison clerk.
Okay.
Medical certificate of
death. Carl pants. Ram.
I hereby certify that I examined the
body of Carl Pans Ram in accordance with
the directions of the surgeon general
of the US public health service and
attorney general at us
penitentiary Leavenworth,
Kansas on September 5th,
1930 and pronounced him dead at 6:18 AM
okay.
I found the cause of death to be
dislocation, cervical vertebra,
strangulation,
legal execution,
and so ended the life of Carl Pans Ram
on September 5th,
1930 and while pans,
Ram died,
evil as we see certainly
did not die with him.
It's still walks among us today.
And as we've been going back and forth on,
I obviously pans.
Ram did not get many benefits in life,
but that does not excuse his actions.
And we are responsible for what we do.
We are responsible for our lives.
And if someone's had a
horrible things happen to them,
if they've seen horrible things,
if they've done horrible things,
it's still important
that you don't be calm.
Those horrible things that you don't
propagate those horrible things.
Okay?
Instead
be the hero,
be the savior that absorbs those things,
those horrible things and passes on good.
And you do that.
You do that by Pete treating people with
respect and being kind to other human
beings.
Okay?
And it's, it's one of those things that
I've thought about this one character,
this does Henry Lesser.
This guard is the first person
that that pans ram ever fought.
Did something nice to him. And who
knows if that had happened earlier,
maybe could have been a
teacher at the state school.
Maybe that's what tips someone
towards the good.
Okay.
You know,
are you that person?
Can you be that person that's sways
someone from doing evil deeds,
doing good simply
crew,
some sympathetic words,
some compassionate gesture.
Think about that.
Might be that person.
I might be that person.
We be that person
that sets the good example
by being nice,
by being kind.
And here's the dichotomy.
At the same time,
you gotta be strong enough to stand up
to people that think might makes right.
You gotta be strong enough to
face the malevolent force of evil.
Yeah.
And you have to recognize
that that is everywhere.
Yeah.
That's say tannic force that is waiting
to prey on the weak.
And if we don't fight it,
the net force has got to win.
Yeah.
So we
cannot stand down.
Hey Tom,
I think that's all I've got for tonight.
Kind of a rough one.
Yes.
When you think about it, this
is like, this is pretty psycho,
like pretty psychotic.
Safeway's evil for sure.
But I dunno if it was just
the way he, it is the, it is.
I do know it's the way
he presented it was like,
it wasn't like as tragic is,
I don't know the other stuff that, that
I've heard, let me take a part of it.
He wrote it and he became
humanized in your head.
So you were listening to him talk and
you were sympathizing with him and you
were understanding the harshness that
he went through and you were completely
detached and not, you didn't humanize
any of the victims at all, right?
Yes. That's what it was opposite of the
beginning when I'm talking about this
beautiful girl Luisa. Yes. From what
she went, you know, you understood her.
Go watch some of the videos of that girl.
Yeah.
You're such a nice person. Yeah.
Like just like an angel. Yeah.
And that's what you relate to.
So as a, as a person yourself,
as a human being yourself,
it's very easy for you to get
three to humanize someone, right.
If you listen to crawl in room,
used to be here,
what he's been through and he's telling
it from his perspective and all these
tiny little 11 year old boy,
you don't know anything about that boy.
Just some arbitrary arbitrary
thing doesn't even barely
exist. It's a word. Yeah.
Boy. That's all it is. Yeah.
But it's not. It's not.
It's a little kid. That's a little
kid. Yeah, that's exactly it.
That's exactly what it was.
You're going through his struggles.
Ensure he's not print
well. Yeah. And you know,
he's talking about his anger and everyone
did sorry. And you're like, Dang,
Okay Bang. That's, you know, he's, he's
a mad guy and sure I'm not, you know,
I'm not siding with him,
but it's,
it's more like you're just getting it
from his Pr, his perspective, you know,
then he dies in your life. Well, you
deserved it. Yeah. Yeah. But if, yeah,
if they'd told that the whole story
of like, I dunno, any one of them new,
one of those victims will be like,
Dang man, this is heavy. It's dark.
Any sorta like, he didn't go into any kind
of graphic detail, you'd just be like,
oh, I commuted, sought him. In fact, I was
like, Bro, how are you even doing that?
You're just like, just sorta committed,
tried to commit. Like how do you do that?
You know, you just, hey, come here, let
me commit sodomy on you. I mean, I dunno.
He made it sound like 200 pound
dude against an 11 year old boy.
Yeah. But even like the, you know, his
inmates or whatever, then everyone,
he was just the, and the point is there,
he just sorta, he's preying on the weak.
He says all the time, he's just
picking a guy that's 132 pounds. Yeah.
But yeah, and just 200 pounds.
Yeah. Six feet. 200 yeah.
You know, he was, I don't know
what the, what the deal is,
but like where I grew up in New England,
the houses like the ceilings are lower
and the doors are smaller because people
were smaller. Yeah. Back in the day,
and this is a hundred years ago,
but we're born ever 90 years ago.
But people are a little bit smaller,
you know,
so him at six foot one 90 is
kinda like a yoke to dude.
Yeah. Plus with all that, you know,
years of hard labor in an 18 pound
hammer. Yeah. You know, he was strong.
Yeah. But he just sorta breezes
over it though. You know,
there's no graphic details. Just sorta.
Yeah. It just committed some bad crimes,
you know?
So that's why it's always good to think
about the perspective of the other
people.
Yeah.
It's crazy, man. It's crazy. But you know,
and yeah, he could have, he should have,
he should have chosen a path is what he
should've done. Like how you said, yeah,
he said that. Right. Well,
more important I think because you're
going to have some people out there that
are going to choose the wrong path.
They're not, they're not going to go,
they're not going to
go in a good direction.
And that's why it's important
to be prepared mentally
and physically to stand up
and face that man. It's true. You got to,
speaking of which, take some
Jujitsu. I'll tell you right now,
you take some Jujitsu,
you really decrease the probability
of anyone attempting sodomy on you.
Yes. It is a big help. Reduce, reduce. Um,
anyway, what that means is
we're going to, regardless of
our, our, our, what we're
trying to defend ourselves from
Jujitsu versus evil. That's what
I'm saying. Yes. It helps you.
Yes. You need all your
tools to fight against evil.
Yeah. Big Time. There's evil
in the world. Confirmed. Yeah.
Fully live evil in the world right now.
Friesen crazy.
Every once in a while I'll flash it will
flash in my mind how valuable Jujitsu
is. Like if you, if
someone said, hey you can,
you can never go to the beach ever again
or you can never do to get to a fair
again. See what I'm saying? Oh you,
you might have some issues.
No, I just think that's funny how like
the two biggest things you can put on the
beach in Jujitsu,
just saying you got to give up one
beach isn't even on my list.
I mean all doesn't to go surfing,
but were just going to the beach for
you as a thing. For me, it's not really,
oh yeah. Well put it this way, like I pry,
could I trade a, I'd give up a
lot to keep Jujitsu if it was,
here's something,
if you know some Jujitsu,
if you know some Jiu Jitsu,
if you know more of Jujitsu than
most other people around you,
that's a real beneficial
thing. Yeah, can you,
and it's funny because if you don't know
anything, you're a little bit ignorant.
In fact, you're in a Latte, right? And
you don't even know what you don't know.
And so you're sitting in, you're, you're
walking across a parking lot, right?
And it's 10 o'clock at night when someone
comes to bother you and you think in
your mind like, oh, just do this and
this and you don't know anything.
It's a complete,
it's a complete whole in your game.
And the game of life is what I'm talking
about. They gave him a life. If it is,
if you know Jujitsu and you're walking
across 10 o'clock at night and someone's
going to give you a problem, you
actually know what to do. Yeah. And,
and the person that doesn't
know anything there, so bar
just behind,
it's crazy.
I remember in college where,
and I knew how to do a rear naked choke
and like, you know, just from watching UFC
never trained to actual Jujitsu class.
But I remember in college I got
into this like fight, right.
And we ended up not fighting,
fighting, but you know,
the kind that we started to fight,
but it was nothing.
You know what it was it a
friend? No. Okay. He was like,
was it a known person
or just a total random,
he was like at a party scenario.
No, I didn't know. Um, and,
and you know, whatever, it doesn't matter
what, how he got broken up, whatever.
And we continued our lives.
But right now I'm thinking back
to like how much I didn't know.
Like what was I even thinking like,
Whoa,
was I going to do just sort of throw
punches, you know, or something like this.
Like what?
Like even when you do get in a fight
and you don't really know any especially
need you to do, it's like
man, you just sort of,
it's sort of a shoot really
compared to if you know Jujitsu,
it's not a crap shoot. It's like, oh, I'm
going to either decide to do whatever.
I want pennant thing to
this person if you want to,
if you don't train Jujitsu and
you want to know what it's like,
picture anything that you
actually know how to do.
Like shoot a basketball
or play basketball.
Yeah. And picture someone that never
played before playing against you.
That's what's going to happen.
Yeah.
If you don't know anything
or like say go find someone.
If you ever can find someone who doesn't
know how to ride a bike or a skateboard.
Yes. Not everyone knows how to ride
a skateboard but a bike and say, hey,
let's race to the end of the block on
this bike and that person doesn't even
know how to write it.
They never been on a bike before.
They have zero chance of it. Btu
I know. Brett's like that. Anyway,
so train some Jujitsu, train some. As
you get to go take some classes. Brad,
just go ahead and go learn how
to ride that bike right now.
Right now in America you can train
Jujitsu and so many different places.
It's amazing. Yeah, it is very amazing.
There's amazing places to train Jujitsu.
So go train some Jujitsu.
Yeah, and when you do,
so you want to do geek end Nogi so
when you get a g, what Geeta we get,
we all know if you don't already origins,
you go to origin may.com I got
a rash guards on there as well.
Joggers as well. Shirts,
supplements, supplements,
of course. And that's a good one to wear.
And I took your advice, you know. Okay.
Remember I told you like Oh yeah a I
didn't take joint warfare for like a few
days. And you're like, what?
Why not other? Cause they
just don't, I don't know,
I forgot or whatever.
Here's the thing,
I admitted something to myself sometimes
when I didn't back then and when I
didn't take it. It's not that I
forgot, it's just that I'd be like,
oh I'll take one tomorrow or
something. I'm like, I'm literally,
I was literally too lazy to just go in
the pantry right here. Not by the way,
like three, four feet away. Get it,
open it up in your routine now bro.
Yes.
And this is how I put it into
my routine and I was like,
there's no way I'm going to be able to
accept the fact that I'm too lazy to
spend literally 20 seconds
literally and you know,
and take some pills.
It's like no way I can accept that,
that I'm not trapped in your brand.
I'm kind of am I guess a little
bit for at least two hours a week.
I'm a little bit trapped in your brand.
Well you're the one who's correcting
it because I'm like no way.
Cause you're like,
dude,
just do it in your routine and you make
it sound so easy cause it doesn't feel
that easy. But then I'm thinking
like, wait, it is that easy. Really.
I'm just not allowing it to put it
by your toothbrush or whatever. No,
I keep it in the pantry. Brow 15 seconds.
Oh, but you just do it. Just do it.
Yeah. Do a little extra.
Very little extra. Anyway.
Check joint warfare. Krill oil. These
are the ones that I'm talking about.
Desert in my routine every single
day. Joints, all situations
to discipline, which if you don't know,
we have a new flavor of discipline out.
It's called Tropic Thunder.
I got mine and let's,
let's be real and let's be
honest, what it, what it is,
peanut peanut Colada,
but I couldn't have something out
there called bt or Gelada. Come on man.
Tropic Thunder. Isn't that a movie? Late
baboons? Favorite movie of all time?
No, actually I don't, but it's right up
there. They've quotes that movie a lot.
I'm going to tell you, I'm going to
tell you right here, I haven't seen it.
You haven't seen tropic thunder.
That's definitely a movie that is so
I think Robert Downey Jr, right? Yeah,
but the most important character
in there is Tom Cruise's character.
He's really,
really funny.
Less good man I think is his name.
And anyways,
so we couldn't call it in clear conscious,
we couldn't call it Pina Colada.
That's just wrong, right? No, not
happening. It's an alcoholic beverage.
We're not doing it. It's kind of a
kind of a foo foo. Is that a good word?
Kind of a food foods like you ever been
to an Italian restaurant or like where
they, where it's real. It's
real nice. It's too nice.
Like they don't have like,
hey can I just get some chicken Parmesan
over here and when they bring you some
food,
it's really small and it has like a
long like name in a different language.
But you know I'm came be put
extras on the name, you know,
you know fresh clot from the Appalachian,
Blah Blah Blah. In the title.
It's like that came but there's never
very much food. The longer the title,
the less food you're going to get.
That's a good rule.
So couldn't go Pina Colada to Fufu.
We went tropic thunder for Leif Babin.
You didn't get as tropic
thunder on it was pretty hot.
And then don't forget about
moke which additional protein?
Additional protein and slash dessert.
Yeah.
Because it will fulfill
your dessert desire. Yeah.
When you get done with the ribeye steak,
so what's the game like when you,
you know when you're going to,
when you lift weights to elicit gains,
you have to have a [inaudible] with a z
you got to eat what,
certain amount of protein or yeah,
it's like 0.7 or 1.6 or just one gram.
Yeah. But here's actually what I
learned with one grab any protein,
like any macro, they eat too much
of get to turn into fat and protein.
Proteins in kits turns to sugar
first from what I understand.
So you can't eat too much protein
is I usually too much protein?
If you're going like two grams
per body weight per pound, right.
What about nine grams per bottle per
pound of body weight? I think that's fine.
Here's a good way to do it. So in
the morning I make a Omelet, right?
With egg whites
and the good protein, clean,
whatever, some of the best.
But when you kind of,
if you're starting,
which I kind of started to measure
these things or keep track of, okay,
how many cal I am,
I really [inaudible] whatever.
So I realize there's not that
much protein in a regular size,
even a double size egg
white omelet with no cheese.
And so boom,
you make your egg white Omelette
train going on the side,
make your milkshake boom, perfect. Oh
milkshake, perfect amount of protein,
cheese. What I'm saying, if
in fact you're into, you know,
getting stronger and what not.
And on top of that we
got warrior kid milk,
which is basically going to take over
all milk drinks for children in the very
short period of time because everyone
wants their kid to be healthy. Yeah.
The kid wants to be healthy and strong
and the kid wants something that tastes
absolutely amazing. So there you
go. Where your kid milk. Yeah.
Remember like back in the day,
what was the fruit Hawaiian
Punch or was that only in Hawaii
Hawaiian Punch back tasted like,
hey, our English muffins. Oh
actually you can just, muffins aren't in
England. It's not a British thing. Yeah,
just like French fries aren't and friends,
right.
I don't they call them like palm
treat something else French anyway.
You know what I'm saying?
You used to drink the Hawaiian Punch
when you're little mouth. I'll read.
Tasted pretty good. Yeah. Well
it's a super strong. Yeah, but bro,
you can't be giving your kids that
like now with no knowledge. Really.
It's chilled child abuse.
And it's not just that these,
these regular chocolate milk. What is
that? It's just corn syrup in milk.
Yeah. That's all it is. And
chocolate and chocolate and sugar.
But we get kid warrior kid
more. Guess what? You're
making them stronger, smarter,
faster,
better and it tastes good and it tastes
delicious because kids don't want to
drink something that tastes like crap.
No, they don't drink something tasty.
So yeah, we're your kid walk all
that stuff that we just talked about.
Is that origin main.com if you want
to set porch, that's a good stuff.
All American made throw that in
there like it's a no big deal. Yeah,
go watch some of the videos of,
of looms being remade.
It's good.
Also if you want to represent while
on the path Jocko was a store.
It's called Jocko store,
so you got a chocolate store.com.
This is where you can get shirts and
whatnot. Discipline equals freedom. Sure.
T shirts, rash guards, plenty, right?
Yes. Other rash guards on their truckers.
Hats or
flex for the hats?
Whichever one you want. Whichever we
are. I like to flip flex it. I'm putting,
I'm going to put a bunch of new stuff
on there. A bunch of 20, 19. It's 2019,
by the way. Happy new year
brother. Thanks for it.
Isn't it funny like I felt like you felt
kind of uncomfortable telling me happy.
Kind of like, it's too like
sentimental. Hey, happy new year bro.
We all work to do. Let's go
focus. All right. New Year.
New gooey there. You know
how they say new year new me.
You got it. I saw, I saw that on
Twitter I think. Anyway. Um, oh yeah.
I'm going to put a bunch of new stuff
there for this year. Okay, cool. Uh,
you can also get Jocko white tea that
comes in either a regular tea form,
like I'm drinking with tea bags or the
can form like echo is drinking with the
can.
And the good thing about it is it's the
only beverage in the history of world
that's guaranteed 100% to give you an
8,000 pound dead lift that's 8,000 pounds.
Don't forget to subscribe to this podcast.
Click subscribe.
So annoying. Okay. Just to this
part, the warrior kid podcasts,
that one you should check out if you
don't check out the warrior kickback ass,
whether you have kids or not, check
it out. Lots of good lessons from,
from Uncle Jake.
So do that.
And then don't forget about
your warrior kids soap.
And it's not soap for warrior kids.
It's soap made by a warrior kid. Aiden,
who's got his own
business@irishoaksranch.com.
Uh,
what's that like Earth made?
He's made well, he gets like
goats. I give you, you want,
you want to know the,
the source of your,
of your like there you go.
What do you say?
Locally sourced local tech.
But nonetheless made in America.
That's true. Okay, so youtube,
you can also subscribe to the Youtube
Channel, which is the Jocko podcast,
youtube channel and are, since you're
putting all this new stuff on the store,
you're going to put some new
videos up at some point in the,
you know America History
American. Yeah, sure.
Yes I am. Thank you. Okay. I know
you were just telling me about one,
you've done this before where you tell
me about a video and I never see it for
four months because like, well, and
this one could be one of those cuts.
It's like I'm going to be like pushing
it. You know? Remember the war path one,
I pushed it in the music and I was like,
hey,
should I make a bunch of things
crumbling down? Is that going to be dumb?
But in the process of doing that,
sometimes I'm like, this is kind of done,
so I got to change it. So
I'm going to see, I want to
push it out of fun, but yeah,
okay, I'm going to try it. How
about that? More, more videos.
And also we've got psychological warfare,
which we have failed.
We were going to get out that for the
new year. We did not accomplish that.
So that's not good.
But we will work on it.
And the current one is available.
Psychological warfare
on iTunes, Google play, MP,
three platforms of all kinds
where you can get little messages.
We'll call from me tracks about how to
overcome a particular weakness that you
might be dealing with in the moment.
I thought about this with
psychological warfare. Sometimes,
like when the weakness creeps in,
we don't want to fight the weakness.
It's like, yeah, like we're like,
it's almost like, okay this is me.
You might not be up to to relate cause
you get mad when you feel like weakness.
Sometimes weakness won't like creep in
and I'll look forward to not lifting,
you know what I mean? Or like, okay, so
there's this burger place.
All right.
I'm not gonna say which one and
to go to this burger places,
certain burger you can get that's
like off the program. You can't. Oh,
okay. It's not a Diet
Burger. Yeah. So when I,
you know, when you're like, oh,
should I just stick to the program,
but I'm really in the mood for this
burger. Right. And the weakness creeps in,
takes hold, and then you made
the decision, all right, hey,
I'm going to slip on the Diet right
now. I'm back on the plan. I'm black,
but I'm back on the program tomorrow,
but I'm going to slip right now.
When you make that decision in
your head, you feel good. Like, oh,
I don't want to change my mind because
I was so looking forward to the burger.
See what I'm saying?
So it's like,
what are those things where the reason
sometimes people won't list, or,
actually this has never happened to me,
but I'm imagining the P,
if someone doesn't want to listen to the
psychological warfare it, that's why.
Because it's like, oh, they just
secretly, they don't want to accept it.
And it's like, you know, and
the except the weakness. Yeah.
This again reminds me that I'm glad I'm
not trapped inside your head for more
than two hours.
Daily strong
nonetheless, psychological or it's a good
one. It helps. It helps you gotta eat.
You gotta accept the hell
you have to do is press play.
That's the point you've got to go.
That's where what you were saying,
you have to press play.
You gotta there's a little psychological
part that you have to accept the fact
that you're going to, you're going
to get a spot. It's like in the gym,
right? When you need a spot in the
gym, you don't put on some lightweight,
you know you get a, if you have a regular
way on, you don't need a spot in cool,
but you got to make the decision to
put the heavy weight on there and then
you've got to make the decision
to go find someone to spot you.
That part is hard for people. That's
what I think. That's what I think.
But once you get the
spot and got the spot,
you're in no danger of getting
buried underneath that, that match.
You see what I'm saying?
Check.
That's a psychological warfare
is can we get it on? Ah, what?
Amazon music and I tunes Apple Music.
You know,
wherever the they sell mp3s, that's where
you get them playing on the core. Fair.
Good one. Very good one. Also
very up your workout man.
Get some more workouts.
Stuff from [inaudible] dot com [inaudible]
dot com slash Jocko that's where you
get that. Got some good stuff on there.
Ropes, battle ropes, maces clubs,
kettle bells of course
the best kettlebells.
Re I mean I'm the best I've ever used.
I mean is that many but I don't even
want to try out any other ones because
they're the best in my opinion and a,
yeah, a lot of good stuff on there.
Let of good tips on there as well
and information on
it.com/truck called good spot.
Also got some books
miking the dragons is out,
it's live and we should not
ever run out of it again.
I printed a lot more so if you
want Mike and the dragons for you,
for your kids, for your
neighbor, kids for your library,
for your school order.
Mike in the dragons does a story that
we'll teach your kids and all children
that read it,
that will stand up and face their fears.
It's so cool to see all the
pictures that people post of like,
oh great, you know, for Christmas and
stuff like that. Also, a lot of kids, uh,
you know, have, this is my kids' favorite
book. This is now my kid's favorite book.
That's pretty cool. So super stoked.
If you haven't read it, check it out.
Miking the dragons.
You can get it on Amazon.
Also weigh the warrior kid and weigh the
warrior kid to Mark's mission and good
news.
I had a deadline of finishing
way the warrior kid three
by New Year's Day guest when I
finished it this morning. Yeah,
years day.
I had to go and finish it before I
worked out because I was at my deadline.
Guess what?
Prioritize your deadline.
My deadline to finish the book.
Good man. So that'll be coming out,
but right now get good,
uh,
way of the warrior kid in way
there were a kid to Mark's mission.
Those are both out discipline
equals freedom field manual.
I know a lot of folk grab that
for Christmas. Appreciate it.
Appreciate most that you're spreading
the word to people that you know,
a little gift. Give someone the gift of
discipline. That's what I'm talking about.
If you want the, the audio
version, it's not on audible.
It's on Amazon music, iTunes,
Google play and other MP3 platforms.
Of course we have extreme ownership,
which was recently,
uh,
made some kind of chart
for the audio book. Leif,
Leif Babin and I read the audio book.
Well,
me and the Texas is Batman reading the
Audio Book and we also read the audio
book for the followup to that book, which
is called the dichotomy of leadership,
which I kicked off today with
a tiny little excerpt. Um,
that's the fallen one
book. And I think, yeah,
some people think it's better.
Interesting.
It makes sense that it is because now
we've written more books and little
more experienced. Learn more. So find
out for yourself dichotomy of leadership.
That one's available.
We also got Ashkelon Font.
That's our leadership consultancy.
We solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do.
If you need help with the leadership at
your organization and if you have any
kind of issue, whatever kind of issue
you have, it's a leadership problem.
It's not a problem of HR.
It's a leadership problem.
It's a not a problem in the
finance department. It's a,
it's a leadership problem.
It's not an operational problem.
It's a leadership problem.
The problem that you have in your
organization as a leadership problem,
if you need help with that,
go to echelon front front.com for details.
Also we got the muster. The muster is
now live. We got Chicago, we got Denver,
we've got Sydney. If you want to come
to the muster leadership conference,
extreme ownership.com all of the musters
have sold out and all the ministers
will sell out.
So if you want to come get there early,
I think there's maybe a ticket or two
left for the live podcasts that we are
recording January 9th in New York City.
If you want to come to that,
try and jump on and buy a ticket real
quick cause it's real close to sold out.
Look forward to seeing their also
f online. So we just launched this.
What this is,
this is an online interactive
leadership training source.
It's myself and the rest of the echelon
front training team puts together,
want to be able to reach more
people. Some of the, you know,
this kind of spawn from organizations
that we work with where they have tens of
thousands or even in some cases hundreds
of thousands of employees and they want
us to train everybody on the fundamental
principles of combat leadership.
Obviously with our six or seven
instructors, we can't do that.
And so we had to figure out a whale
way to scale the educational process.
And so what we did is we went to virtual
and so we put this together and once we
made it we said, well
what's it? We've made it.
We're making it director to consumer as
well. So if you want to check that out,
you can go to e f online.com e f
online.com and speaking of Def,
yeah, for Overwatch. This is where
we are connecting proven leaders,
proven combat leaders from
the SPEC ops community.
And from combat aviation with companies
in the civilian sector that need these
experienced leaders to step up
and lead their organizations.
So eff overwatch.com is where
you can get involved with that.
Whether you're someone that's looking for
talent, you can click on talent seeker,
whether you're someone Yvette
that's looking for career,
click on career seeker and fill those out.
We are standing by to help you
and if you want to cruise with us
kind of hard.
Yes sir.
We can be found and communicated
with on the interwebs on Twitter,
on Instagram and on the face sheet.
Echo is at echocharles and I am
at Jocko Willink. And finally,
thanks to all our military
personnel out there.
Thank you for standing up and taking
the fight to the enemy into our folks at
uniform in uniform here at home,
including police and law enforcement
and firefighters and paramedics,
knee mts and the correctional officers
and border patrol and all the first
responders.
Thank you for standing
up to evil here at home
and to Louisa,
Jess Pearson and Morin Ulan
who were murdered in Morocco.
Okay,
we will remember you
and to the despicable.
Okay.
Savages that took your lives.
We will remember you too.
Then we'll remember those like you,
and we will never surrender
to the evil that you bring into the world.
We will stand up,
we will be strong and we will win.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko.
How.